e
e e
good morning today is Monday March 3rd
2025 this is the New Hampshire House of
Representatives Municipal and County
government committee I am representative
Diane power the committee has convened
today to hold hearings as well as
executive sessions now please make sure
that your cellones are silenced and
please join us in reciting the Pledge of
Allegiance led by representative
Elward to the FL of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
thank
you so before we begin public hearings I
have a few morning announcements as I
had said the committee has convened at
9:00 a.m. for the purpose of public
hearings on five bills after the public
hearing scheduled
for
10:30 uh 10:30 yeah the committee will
break for lunch and we May hold
executive sessions on pending
legislation throughout the day if we
have some extra time in between
hearings um as has been properly
noticed at this time the chair will open
the public hearing on House Bill 471
establishing a commission to study
issues related to growth traffic and
planning and land use for certain
towns and the chair recognizes
representative Perez to introduce the
bill to the committee this morning good
morning and welcome to Municipal and
County government good morning thank you
chairman and thank you committee members
um I am here actually representing uh
representative Ron Dunn as he was unable
to make it here today to present this
bill to you um presently so this bill
would establish a commission to study
issues related to the growth traffic and
planning and land use for certain towns
and it's actually taking 10 Towns um
that some are from different planning
committees and the reason um I'll get
into a little bit why but presently as
you I'm you all know presently uh
Rockingham uh Planning Commission serves
27 towns nashwa 13 towns Southern New
Hampshire planning serves 14 towns
currently the nine Regional planning
commissions they serve on an advisory
only to the local towns and with the
goal of promoting growth use and
transportation and Environmental
Protection this commission would examine
several things it would look at the
purpose and direction of the nine uh
planning commissions it would also
perhaps offer an option to
reconfigures in the nine planning
commissions so that they would better
serve the to um they would better serve
each town and also do we possibly need
to redraw the map for the nine rate
Regional plannings to better serve each
town this bill um was requested by
multiple sever a bit ago um by several
um residents in London AR which I um
represent and the town manager at the
town as well as several of the Town
counselor it takes towns with similar
locations size and
development to share and um to share
best practices so this will be a
temporary commission to last only until
the goal could be accomplished to offer
recommendations to the um existing
commissions so
I know commissions are not popular right
now but these towns have been selected
it's my understanding according to
representative Dunn because they are
looking at um growth um transportation
issues um traffic issues they're looking
at a lot of very similar issues that
perhaps the commission that they might
be part the planning uh group that they
might be in
they don't all have those problems so
that's basically to bring these together
to try to see how we can best
accommodate these and perhaps look at
how redoing some of the things might um
serve all the all the residents and all
the
communities I will take questions from
you all I hope I can answer them I'm
hoping that the gentlemen behind me may
have more information than me so thank
you thank you representative Perez are
there questions for representative
Perez had a question so I see in this
this bill that this is for to establish
a commission to do a study correct and
on page two Roman numeral six it the
commission will report findings to the
um for
legislation so I'm trying to understand
what type of legislation might come out
of this commission as opposed to the
whole purpose is to study Solutions
right for growth traffic planning and
land use
so could could these purposes be
accomplished at the local level through
ordinances in and to help me to
understand the answer to that question
do you have any idea of what type of
legislation might be
needed I can tell you honestly I do not
my only thought might be and I'm all for
local representation and local
ordinances
um I are the commissions pardon my
ignorance on this but are these are the
planning um are the planning commissions
are they established via
legislation and if they are would
legislation have to be enacted to
perhaps readjust them or reconfigure
them so that's
my somewhat uninformed possibility
answer thank you further
questions representative Jama is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um the question I have is to do
with the cities that were decided on
this okay do we know um what group or
who decided on these cities and I can
see that there's no um like Lebanon or
Kean or any of those kind of Western
cities and wanted to know if there's
kind of maybe an amendment possibility
for that well I think it's my
understanding and according to
representative Dunn is that these um
towns share common locality as far as
one of them is the uh access to Southern
New Hampshire uh Route 93 was one of
them um these um when Ron reached out
through um commissions through the
Planning Commission
these were towns it's my understanding
that specifically asked to be part of it
because of their similarities in
location as well as
um what's going on in the towns as far
as their growth I know London Dairy we H
we're having mega growth right now um
and we have um transport big
transportation in issues um traffic
issues I should say so I think these
towns felt that they were similar in a
lot of the ideas now marac doesn't
necessarily access 93 but it does but it
also has route three so I think that was
the
reasoning representative frock is
recognize for a question thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um I just want to reiterate my
understanding of the purpose of this
commission um
these 10 Towns are currently in
different Regional planning commissions
that's my understanding some and they
are desirous because of common needs to
be in a single Regional Planning
Commission is that correct not
necessarily not necessarily that would
be up to being the
commission they are what this commission
would do is see if that was an option to
redistrict or replan planning
Commissions in order to accommodate
towns better for example um some of the
towns have uh like like nasua has I
think 13 um 13 towns um I don't know if
small towns is maybe perhaps Brookline
is part of the nashille one you know
what
is can a commission that's looking at a
city of Nashville
also directly meet the needs of a town
with much fewer
people you're welcome further
questions representative majority is
recognized thank you madam chairwoman
thank you for taking my question um
growth is both residential growth and
Commercial growth because you said
there's explosive growth so I just want
to make sure it's it's both of them is
intended yes both are intended
right additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Eric
power good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair and
good morning committee members uh for
the record my name is Eric power I'm
from Brookline I also Ser been serving
on the Brookline planning board since
2021 so I'm going to my fifth year and
I'm speaking in favor of House Bill
471 I think it's a good bill having
experience on planning the planning
board um I can see the need for this for
these towns these towns are all um in
and around the uh Manchester and nsha
areas south C central New Hampshire and
as such they share a lot of common uh
needs that it's a system here you got to
think of it I'm a system engineer um for
my uh professional background but it's a
system here with all these towns and
there they're spanning three different
Regional planning commissions um
Brookline and the towns west of nsha and
Two Towns East are in the regional
Planning Commission National Regional
Planning Commission but you also have
Rockingham Regional Planning Commission
represented in Southern New Hampshire
Regional Planning Commission so um when
things happen within the regional
Planning Commission there's some um
ability there to work but when things
start spanning across uh Regional
planning commissions that gets a little
more difficult and so um whenever we
look at a project in U in our town one
of the things that's on our checklist is
we have to go through and do uh a
finding if this is a development of
regional impact
um and that's an important thing to do
and most of them are not but
occasionally you'll get one maybe it's
on the edge of town we also border
Massachusetts so we have that that that
situation as well but when you have a
development of regional impact you have
to work with the other towns if you find
that have that finding it gets a little
bit more challenging when you cross over
the boundaries um of the uh Regional
planning commissions so I think it makes
a lot of sense um for them to have the
this Commission because they all share
in the 93 and Route three corridors and
there's a lot of residential growth
there's a lot of commercial growth and I
think them cooperating in a commission
like this makes a lot of sense they get
a common understanding and I think what
would come out of it and I would
recommend in maybe in in paragraph six
if if you found necessary um I think
that it wouldn't just be necessarily
proposed legislation proposed
legislation may help Drive the State
Highway plan if this commission had some
findings because obviously they're
dealing a lot with the highways but you
could also and it might be a
reconfiguration of the regional planning
commissions if it made sense maybe we
need a tenth one in New Hampshire and
takes into account that center part of
New Hampshire that might be something
that comes out of it I'm just saying
that as a possibility but there might
also be projects of regional impact that
get identified as a re as part of this
commission that would be something that
could be um wouldn't have to be
legislation but it would actually set at
the stage for them to cooperate on on
plans would wouldn't necessarily need
reg uh this um legislation to do it but
they would actually the commission would
have that good and I think if these 10
Towns really want to get together and do
this I think it makes a lot of sense to
enable us by a commission and it also
has the piece of having legislators you
know they they're not mandating a state
representative to be a member although
they can be but it's a member of it's
it's a state representative a town
council member or a select board member
or even a planning board member from
each of the towns making up this
commission so I think they've let it
made it flexible to meet make meet the
needs of south southern New Hampshire
and for these reasons I would recommend
a to pass or a to pass with Amendment on
House Bill 471 and that concludes my
testimony and I'll take questions thank
you questions representative Gilman is
recognized thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question
um have you looked at RSA
3646 which does what you're asking to do
in
this I have not looked at 3646 no I
haven't thank
you further questions representative J
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um I wanted to know
do you think that we could make this
bill more broad so other cities maybe in
different locations could do this within
themselves as well and we don't have to
keep coming back to passing the same
thing just for different
cities thank you representative for the
question I think there's probably other
areas of the state that are probably
experiencing similar growth but they're
not in this Locust here but you know I
think about the Upper Valley I think of
Lebanon and Hanover Enfield that area
they and then maybe they have to
consider their neighbors across Austin
Vermont um that might be something that
would be worthy if this became a bill
that would make this an easier process
perhaps RSA 3646 allows this in some way
I think that has to be looked at by the
committee but uh and maybe even you know
you look at the Mount Washington Valley
up in Conway in that area I'm thinking
of the the growth that's happening up
there um if you don't plan these things
if the planning boards and the the the
governing bodies don't plan good things
might not happen but if they do
um if you have these sort of
cooperations I think it would make a lot
of sense so I would agree if you can
find a mechanism to allow these
commissions to happen um you may not get
the the only thing you wouldn't get is
maybe the uh contribution of the state
representatives necessarily and that's
why this one that's why this proposal is
good but you have to kind of wrestle
with that a little bit I think the
intent is good I think everybody
probably agrees about it but is is you
know how how do we make these happen and
how do they make them easier to happen
across the state to have the cooperation
we're looking
for representative stavis has a question
thank you madam chair and I apologize to
my colleagues and uh to you for being
late this morning um thank you for
taking my question um following up on my
colleague Julie Gilman's question 3646
specific specifically provides a
mechanism for two or more towns in the
state to create a regional Planning
Commission so again I'm going to ask why
this is necessary when the mechanism to
do what it wants to do already exists in
law thank you for the question I am not
familiar with the a regional Planning
Commission I think is formed by
legislation if it's maybe a slightly
different term um because there's nine
every town belongs to one of nine
Regional planning commissions so you
can't be in two of them at the same time
as my understanding um so maybe it's a
different term maybe there's a different
kind of commission that they could they
could stand up um so if that exists
maybe that that would be something that
could be recommended as uh the solution
here representative Colby is recognized
for a question thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question
um one very strange thing and it goes
back to the makeup and the selection of
of the towns um town that have been left
out but are a
Butters if you will using a planning
board term um Dunbarton for example uh
is laying in between gtown and
hookit um
plastow uh also missing from the list
even though very close to Windom and
sharing uh traffic
patterns um is there any concern that
these towns will feel strong armed um by
large larger
communities by being left out of the
conversation thank you for the question
I I don't know the um exact way that
they developed this list but I was you
know when I looked at it knowing the
geography a little bit I was looking at
it and I thought of dun Barton I my
brother used to live in Dunbarton so I
know the town also plastow that's sort
of in the same Corridor so they may want
to be at as asked if they want to be on
the list if the state reps want to maybe
be consulted because I think they it is
a system at some point you have to cut
it off but if you look at the the what
was selected um it might make sense to
include those at least those two
examples you would then have 12
communities when the commission gets a
little too large it may not be as
effective or it gets a little harder to
do things but uh you have to balance
that with not leaving folks out I think
I I think that's a good
suggestion representative frock is
recognized for a question thank you
madam
chair um I notice on the list of
members that there's nobody representing
the three regional planning commissions
is that an
oversight thank you for the question I
was um that was another suggestion I was
going to make when I looked at this bill
I was not involved with this bill bill
at all I just happened to see it and
wanted to give my input as a planning
board member um that it would make sense
for I would say the commission to
include one person from each of those
three regional planning commissions I
think that would make a lot of synergy
happen and um if they were not voting
members at least they would be
Consulting members if you wanted to make
them that I think that would be a good
uh good thing to include is to have them
involved because it does span multiple
Regional Planning Commission so good
good
suggestion thank you Mr power additional
questions representative Gilman thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
another question um I believe the uh
Rockingham Planning Commission and the
southern district Planning Commission do
overlap and it was presented to the
exitor select
board to uh do you mind if we do this
sharing the same complex so um I guess
my question is still on chapter 36 of
the RFA is that what you're asking to do
is already
established I don't know if that there's
a question there but I would say is it
already
established I do not I would not be able
to answer that specifically I the
Southern New Hampshire I'm not I'm in
the National Regional Planning
Commission so I tend to know most of
that more than I know the adjacent ones
but um the Southern New Hampshire and
the Rockingham Regional planning
commissions uh would be pieces of this
and if you look at RSA 3646 and you
think that that's going to achieve the
same goal of what this legislation is
then you could you could uh handle it
accordingly further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you do we have another card okay
so that was the last pink card that I
have on this
bill is there anyone present who wishes
to speak on this bill who has not yet
had the opportunity to do so U seeing
none the chair will recognize
representative Gilman to report out the
blue sheets for House Bill 471
sorry Madame chair I had a little delay
in that's okay take your time
uh on the remote signin we had uh two in
support and three
opposed and on the blue sheet we had one
in
support thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
e
e e
it's uh 9:30 and I'm going to open the
public hearing on House Bill
local uh representative powers please
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as a prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
you today House Bill 373 local for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
in Greenville in Hillsboro County
District
36 this bill was filed to address
deficiencies in the law pertaining to
town property found under RSA
4111 col
11-a which I recognize during my
participation in a committee of
conference last legislative session
the problem that I found is There's no
practical provision under the current
law that allows for the lease of public
property for longer than 5 years
currently under this statute there are
only two options available the first is
that the statute gives Selectmen the
blanket authority to rent or lease
unused public property for up to one
year and the second option that's
allowed under statute is that the legis
that the legislative body can vote to
authorize the Selectmen to be able to
enter into a lease for up to five years
and this um this vote by the legislative
body is done at an annual or a special
town meeting under current RSA for a
lease agreement of town property for a
time period longer than 5 years the
legislative body is required to come
back and every 5 years to reauthorize
that Authority for the select board to
continue leases otherwise the lease
terminates while this might make sense
for a number of cases it's impractical
in other cases and to explain I I would
like to offer two examples demonstrating
the um lack or the deficiency in the
current law so the most recent example
is um with regards to the half a billion
dollar Hampton Beach Casino ballroom
Redevelopment project that was um being
proposed last year and um so what what
was going on there is that the town of
Hampton wanted to lease or enter into a
long-term
lease with the abutter of a very short
um road that was less than a tenth of a
mile in Hampton and under current law
the legislative body could only
authorize the town to lease this and it
was only 435.214
for this short bit of road that was
unused could only be in 5year increments
um didn't make sense so as a result
every five years the legislative body
under the current law would like I said
would need to reauthorize the select
board to be able to continue the lease
for another five years again otherwise
the lease would
terminate
and the second example um occurred in
where the voters in Brookline passed a
warrant article to allow the select
board to lease Parcels of town property
that were situated around a pond in town
to multiple tenants for a term of 13
years and so since the lease was 13
years which is greater than 5 years the
RSA 4111 a requires that the voters come
back every 5 years in order to be able
to give theth authority to the select
board to be able to continue um the
leases after that initial warrant
article had been approved by the
legislative body so as a result last
year in 2024 at town meeting we had a
warrant article to allow the Selectmen
to extend those leases for another five
years because you can only go five years
which was passed by voters and now in
2029 the voters will see an additional
warrant article again to allow the
selectman to continue the to further
extend the lease for an additional 3
years in order to get to the 13 years
which had been approved by the voters so
um additionally I conducted some
research and I have this handout which
lists 12 examples of proposed um warrant
articles for Town property leases that
exceed 5 years so I feel that there is a
demonstration ated need for this um
change in statute so the solution is the
bill which addresses the problem by
adding a provision that allows for the
legislative body by a vote at an annual
or special meeting to be able to
authorize the select board the ability
to rent or lease unused Town property
for more than a year so um to briefly ex
summarize the the changes that this bill
373 makes is under section one the
default Authority for the town um select
board to manage Town property is Remains
the Same I just changed the word to be
consistent with other um parts of
Statute and then in section three I mean
section two that's that's uh reorganized
in new section so under section two the
authority to rent or leas town property
is provided under three options lines 11
through 12 under a if the lease is less
than a year then the select board has
the authority to enter into any such
lease in lines 13 through 21 if the
lease is greater than a year then the
legislative body shall vote to give the
select board the authority to enter into
that specific lease and the vote
threshold for approval is a 3- fifths
majority by ballot and then under
Section Roman numeral 3 is the option
provision which is currently in law in
which the legislative body may vote to
give the select board the authority to
lease any Town property for up to five
years that's a blanket Authority and
it's um optional and
enabling and again the vote threshold is
a three-fifths majority to by ballot to
adopt as well as to resend this 5year
Authority and also if the legislative
body votes to send the authority
importantly any existing leases shall um
remain valid in in effect so to conclude
the bill maintains the ability of the
select board to lease property for less
than a year it grants the select board
the ability to lease a specific property
for more than a year but less than 99
years by a 3- fifths majority vote of
the legislative body and 9 year 99 years
is just it's a it's a legal um I guess
term or time period that means a longer
period of
time and then lastly the bill preserves
The Five-Year gr Grant of leasing
authority of any Town property to the
select board but with a three-fifths
majority vote of the legislative body so
for these reasons I urge the committee
to recommend House Bill 373 local op to
pass thank you Mr chairman and I'm happy
to answer
questions thank you representative
question questions for the
representative representative
Colby thank you Vice chair uh and thank
you for taking my
question I'm concerned as to how we went
from uh statement of ratified by vote of
the town to a 35ths majority
required
so could you reference the line number
all right um so line number nine crosses
out uh shall not be valid unless
ratified by vote of the Town correct
yeah okay um and then we changed that
provision to say uh that now we're
putting a threshold on voting so now the
vote has to be a 3- fifths
majority correct so the the original
bill
the the original statute has by vote of
the town which implies that it's a
simple majority so I thought that it was
important and so by virtue of Statute
like I had um outlined that the select
board has the authority to rent or lease
unused property for up to a year so then
we have that we have the scenario where
you the the the legislative body May
Grant blanket Authority for a time
period for up to five
so we have that and then in what this
bill is is trying to address is that
that Gap in between so due to the fact
that it's greater it's we're talking
about a a lease agreement that's greater
than five years this is a long-term um
commitment and Authority so I felt that
it was important
to to have a majority super majority a
three- fifths rather than just a simple
majority so um cuz if we're talking
about like say for example the the
Hampton
Road situation that that's that's that's
serious so I I felt that it warrants a
greater um support
or ratification by the legislative body
because that's you see what I'm saying
yes thank you thank
you any other
questions thank
you okay there now call Mr Eric power
good morning Mr
power good morning Mr ice chair and
committee
members uh for the record my name is
Eric power from Brookline representing
myself I also serve on the Brookline
planning board I'm going into my fifth
year starting in
2021 uh I'm supporting this bill because
I think it's an important bill I I talk
to um planning board members from the
rest of national Regional Planning
Commission at various meetings come up
with this problem we have in Brookline
where we have our this melandy Pond
Authority um where we have leases of
properties there's approximately 17
properties that um are leased and each
year almost inevitably one of them comes
up um with leases expiring the intent is
to have leases that go about 13
years and it's almost a perennial at our
town meeting that we have to go and vote
to yep you get another five years and
it's almost an every every year we're
almost seeing this on our town warrant
and people are asking why can't we just
say we want to go to 13 years and vote
on that and let the people have that um
that certainty of you know not having to
worry about the lease not maybe not
getting renewed because people are
building houses you know houses on these
land leases and um
it comes back to the RSA
411a does not allow that and that's why
there's a purpose of this legislation
and in talking to others they found that
some are trying to do um things like
lease Town land for a mobile wireless
tower like a cell tower other ones want
to lease uh Town property for solar
arrays and they're limited by able to do
this in 5year renewable increments and
some projects just don't happen because
some uh some people that want a lease
want the certainty of more than 5 years
if they're going to make an investment
in standing up solar panels or going to
do something else they want and the
example that was brought up earlier was
about in Hampton where they wanted to be
able to you know use the land for
development they didn't want to invest
all this money in a development and then
have to worry in five years it might be
resented and all that investment goes
away so um it makes a lot of sense to
give the legislative body of the Town a
three-fifth ballot vote in order to
authorize these three fifths makes a lot
of sense because we do this on a lot of
uh warrant articles that have multi-year
impacts such as bonds such as you know
adopting sb2 such as a tax cap or a
budget cap so it makes sense for
something that endures for a long period
of time to have that super majority
agreement because it will impact the
town for many years um in the case of a
long lease of 99 years it certainly
makes a lot of sense to have the
Three-Fifths so um for those reasons I
would recommend the bill to be passed
recommended OTP out of committee I think
it'll do a lot of good across the state
for those that are trying to lease Town
property give them the mechanism and in
the enabling legislation they need en
able to have these longer leases of town
property and I will take any questions
thank you
thank you Mr power any questions from Mr
power oh representative
grind thank you thank
you and thank you for taking my question
and I probably should have asked it to
representative power maybe you can
answer this when and the part three
you're it's changing the three my
majority for a lease for up to five
years from just a majority so if there
are are current leases that are 5 years
and they're coming up for Renewal are
you now potentially requiring a three
fifths to pass and a lease that's
happened in the past will no longer pass
and become null and
void thank you for the question I'm
trying to dissect your question a little
bit um so if you've already given
authority to the town you've had this
you did this enabling
legislation that still stays in effect
and if it doesn't if you don't have it
then you would have to uh pass this
Authority at the three-fifth level I
know that that appears to be a change um
from current law but I think it makes a
lot of sense when you're giving a
blanket Authority um I think that
requires a little bit higher level of uh
approval that's my personal opinion um
and right now it's a simple
majority could I have a quick followup
followup go ahead um would it
potentially to because there's a grading
of one year five year and then over five
years would it make sense more to have
majority to pass at a fiveyear and then
the three fifths to pass if it's greater
than five
years thank you for the question I think
that's a policy decision I would not be
opposed to that if that's something the
committee felt was a stronger um uh way
to go um I think three fifths I think
most people would agree for more than
five years makes sense for the up to
five years the blanket Authority I'm
kind of on the fence on that I kind of
think it's important I think it should
be a ballot vote instead of a simple
card vote but um that's something the
committee to decide I think that's an
area that could be
refined representative
Colby thank you thank you for taking my
question um I'm going back also to the
the 3- fifths majority being required um
I know we're talking about expenditures
uh in a lot of the examples uh that
you've given um municipalities are
desperate for Revenue generating
projects uh to drive down the cost of
property taxes at this time
so the concern I think to piggyback on
uh representative grund is if you are in
a revenue generating lease on a a cell
tower site on a solar um site and you
are generating good Revenue through
Pilots or um payment in Le of
taxes
then you have shifted to a 3- fifths
majority being
required outside of your five years that
you've already signed on if that were to
fail
then then that's a huge loss of Revenue
and
I what would you what what would be the
I mean you've signed a lease um with a
company for 30 years you've been
authorized to sign that lease for 30
years by the legislative body uh why now
go back I guess and then require a 3-
fifths on top of
that I think I understand your question
so you're talking about a lease that's
been renewed at 5-year intervals if if
the legislative body has given that
blanket Authority you already have the
blanket Authority um so the three-fifth
vote is a one-time vote for any lease
for up to five years so that would
continue as it would today um the the
the the Major Impact would be those who
have not voted to have a um given this
authorization at all to their town for
up to 5 years they would need to get
that onetime vote of 3 fifths I don't
think the 35th would be a difficult
thing to get especially if it's going to
help the town generate um Revenue
because that will help all taxpayers
generally speaking um so I think that
would make sense I think it makes sense
for the long-term individual leases so
you got to remember this legislation is
talking
about a c three categories one is up to
a year which the Selectmen can do on
their
own they don't need the the voters they
can go up they can then they can get a
blanket Authority for any
lease if it if once the voter's give
that Authority they can do that for any
lease they can renew it for up to five
years they don't have to revote on that
and then the third category is the new
category which is leases over five years
you vote on those leases on an
individual basis on a specific basis for
that lease so if if you do a 30-year
lease you vote on it for 30 years and
that's a three- fifths vote those last
two categories are three-fifths
votes any other questions representative
Murphy thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
for taking my
question how did you get the three-
fifths why not 2/3 that's still a super
majority thank you for the question um
the seems like the the precedent that's
been set in Municipal and School
District law has been for most things to
be a three-fifth majority today we used
to have um I think up to about five
years ago bonds at a traditional meeting
required a
two3 majority vote but that got changed
to three- fifths uh 2/3 is a very high
standard I think that that's uh
unusually high standard for things there
are a few laws out there that I'm aware
of that have the two-thirds but um even
in traditional towns passing a bond is
now at the three-fifth vote most other a
lot of enabling legislation there simple
majority or three-fifths so it made
sense to sort of stay with that
three-fifths if the committee felt 2/3
was more plausible you know I would not
be against that but I think that is a
very high standard to try to
pass any other
questions seeing that Mr power thank you
very
much committee calls uh Mr Brody
desay morning Mr Des thank you Mr Vice
chairman uh thank you to the committee
for hearing my testimony today my name
is birie Dees I represent the Hampshire
Municipal Association and um we are
currently opposed to House Bill 337 as
written um House Bill 33 373 sorry um
House Bill 373 continues to allow a
select board to lease or rent land up to
one year without voter approval it also
expands the lease of rental duration the
legislative body May Pro May approve
without needing another vote by the by
the legislative body to not exceed 99
years instead of the existing 5 years
under RSA 41 11-a um it also changes the
threshold um for voter approval to a
35th super majority rather than the
existing majority to permit the select
board to enter into a rental or lease
agreements of up to 5 years without
getting further approval from the
legislative body annually um our
specific intention is with lines uh 22-
25 and lines
13-4 I'll read briefly lines 22 through
2 quote the legislative body may vote by
a 3- fth super majority at an annual or
special meeting to Grant the select
board The Authority or resend such
Authority previously granted to rent or
lease any Municipal property under their
control for a term of up to 5 years um
the way we also read this bill is it
would require um votes by ballot at
traditional town meeting um which hasn't
been the standard currently um it would
also override the existing votes by
legislative bodies in municipalities
that have approved um leases of up to 5
years um now require revote to be in
accordance with these statutes um
there's no language that says the leases
prior to this bill being enacted should
it become law would remain unchanged and
not impacted and that's one of our
deepest concerns um this could also
raise some concerns with some
municipalities or those Leasing and
renting their land or property that this
bill could be construed as retroactive
and so for those reasons while we
appreciate the expansion of um the local
control to permit uh municipalities with
approval from their legislative bodies
to enter into agreements of up to 99
years with still the legislative body's
ability to resend those agreements um
the 3- fth super majority would be a
change in the possibilities of this
being construed as retroactive or
requiring um new votes or that would
need three-fifths um voter approval to
enter into lease agreement um would be
something municipalities would have to
deal with and could negatively impact uh
their uh efficiency and Effectiveness in
governing um locally and with that I
will take any questions thank
you thank you Mr Des any questions for
Mr
Des represent
Davis thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you for taking my question be uh kind of
inartfully worded question but the gist
is is there a state kind of trip wire
where 2/3 becomes three fifths and is
there a rationale behind when that
happens I'm wondering if you could
rephrase your question I think I
understand what you're asking but I want
to make sure I ask it correctly sorry
answer correctly most voting is simple
majority in some cases it's a super
majority is there any kind of Statewide
not law but kind
of guard rail that says a
vote a matter of this importance
requires a super majority are there any
categories of
decisions that legislative bodies make
that require three-fifths decision as
opposed to a simple majority what I'm
trying to get at is what's the rationale
for moving a simple majority to a super
majority
um so I can speak to my understanding I
can't speak to the rationale of um why
legislators have changed the laws
previously from majority to uh super
majorities but my understanding is that
when it's long-term agreements
especially those that involve taking on
debt so like a bond there's a belief
that you need a super majority of the
voters who tend to be the taxpayers to
agree to take on that whether it's a
15-year Bond or a 30-year Bond because
they will be paying off that debt for a
long duration of time um so it's tended
to be the legislature's prerogative to
um require the legislative bodies and
municipalities to have a three- fths
majority to pass on long-term agreements
um especially those where the
municipality will be taking on
additional um debt
burden any other
questions seeing n thank you mras thank
you that was the last pink p is there
anyone else that would like to
testify seeing then we'll report the
blue sheet once we have it
representative Gilman do you have
anything to report yes sir on the remote
testimony uh there's five in support and
zero opposed and the blue sheet is
blank thank you I now close the hearing
on HB 373 local
I'm now going to open up the hearing on
hb413 413 relative to subdivision
regulations on the completion of
improvements and the regulations of
building
permits Comm we like to call
Representative Diane power please
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor
of House Bill 4
413 I appreciate the opportunity to
present this bill to you for your
consideration for the record I am
representative Diane power I represent
the towns of Brookline Mason and
Greenville in Hillsboro County District
36 house bill 14 43 was filed upon the
request of the Prime sponsor of 2024
house bill to
12:15 this bill passed the house on
consent calendar unfortunately when this
that bill went to the other chamber not
one but two non-gain amendments were
amended onto the bill and the committee
of conference report failed in the
house in general this bill provides
flexibility to developers enabling large
projects to be undertaken and completed
over a number of years with with lower
risk thereby providing our state with
the much needed
housing that is needed the bill does
this in three important ways first the
bill extends the existing fiveyear
exemption for subdivision plats um an
additional two years to seven years for
completion and it also increases the
preliminary step to get the project
actively and substan substantially
underway from 2 years to 3 years
secondly the bill changes the building
code and fire code appeals process
limiting the jurisdiction of the local
building board of appeals to hearing
decisions made under local amendments to
those
codes importantly this provides relief
for appeals by a developer from having
to have to first appeal to the local
Zoning Board of adjustment or the board
of Selectmen when they are acting as the
local building code board of appeals for
State Building Code or state fire code
disputes instead the developer can
directly appeal to the State Building
Code review board which will speed up
the the process overall thirdly the bill
provides that approved subdivision plats
site plans and building permits shall be
required to meet all the State Building
Code fire code and Municipal zoning
ordinances in existence and in full
effect at the time the development plans
were
approved importantly the Subdivision
plat will be exempt from any subsequent
changes in the codes or regulations made
after the approval for the
project um when when the approval for
the project was granted by the
municipality for up to seven years so
long as that project is actively and
substantially underway within the
three-year time period so why is this
important well that provision prevents
escalating costs as a result of the
developer needing to have to go back and
redo work after a project had been
approved to certain building codes and
um
regulations that were in time that were
in place at the time that the project
was
approved in in order to meet the the
newly adopted codes and regulations and
again this is
important for large scale projects
because it reduces risk to the to the
developer and it encourages them to be
able to take on larger projects that
take more time to complete
without incurring additional costs
and that impedes getting the housing out
that that we need to solve the housing
crisis so to explain that because I
think it might that that provision might
have been a little bit confusing so the
problem that is occurring is that in
some municipalities they're withholding
the certificates of occupancy when the
development project takes longer than
five years after that project had been
approved by the planning board
and so
I the prime sponsor of the the previous
bill and I also agree that it's
preferable for the subdivision approval
to be
extended to seven years under the
original terms which would be under the
original fire codes State building codes
and ordinances and any other
requirements that were in existence when
that plan was the development plan plan
was approved so the bill also corrects
an oversight in RSA 673 colon 3 that
some for some reason it's stated that
only an elected zoning board could be
could serve as the local building code
board of appeals so I corrected that
error under in the language of this bill
in front of you so that either an
elected or an appointed zoning Board of
adjustment may act as the local building
code board board of
appeals and
um finally I have compiled a side by
side um document comparing because
there's a lot of parts and pieces to
this and it looks overwhelming but when
it's laid out it it's very it's simple
and and it's clear so in order to
communicate that to you I prepared the
side-by-side document comparing the
current law House Bill
413 and you'll see um I have it
highlighted hopefully it's a gray
highlight for you the the changes and
that text is in bold and also comments
explaining exactly what the amended
language does to conclude I um I urge
the committee to recommend house bill
for 13 ought to pass to help streamline
the building process and to enable
developers to be able to build more of
the housing that the granite state needs
thank you Mr chairman that concludes my
bill introduction and happy to take
questions thank you representative
questions for representative
power representative Frank thank you Mr
Vice chair um Vice
chair uh representative power in your
research over the last say 10 years how
much of a problem has it been for
developers to exceed the current time
frame thank you for the question
representative so as I explained that
this bill I haven't been a state rep for
10 years but I I can certainly
research so as I explained that this
bill was filed at the request of the
Prime sponsor of TW the a bill last year
which was 1215 so I am the that
individual um is not a state rep this
this this term so he asked me to file
this
bill and so I
guess in his research in filing the bill
last year apparently he he saw that
there was a need for this additionally
this um goes along with the governor's
plan to streamline um building and the
development process and to enable
developers to be able to build the much
needed housing that need here in the
state I hope that answers your question
um it does and if you or perhaps the
former representative could provide some
research to the committee that would be
helpful thank you any other
questions rep stavis thank you Mr Vice
chair and thank you for taking what I
think will be a
question um
um I'm wondering why you think an
extension is needed given certain sets
of examples that I could give from
Lebanon where where development is
proceeding a pace on many many different
fronts with literally several hundred
units of housing coming online within
the 2-year framework uh the only two
developments in my 8year on the Lebanon
planning board that that had to be given
extensions extensions after extensions
where a not housing developments and B
one of them is going into year 16
now uh at Great Peril to the city at
great financial burden to the
taxpayers and I just think that
if so many developers can get so much
work done in the a lotted I under
current law why do you think this is
needed now when so many of them are
getting it done thank you for the
question representative well I um
applaud the developers that are able to
to get things um to get their
projects underway and going and and
completed I would say that as we all
know that the housing be it houses
Apartments
Etc we don't have enough we don't have
enough here in the state and
um so what I would say let me just make
this comment so with regards to um
changing it from you know 5 to 7 um to
be clear the the the bill 2015 changed
it for five from 5 to 10 and I thought
that that was too much so I dialed it
back on on
with my own discretion to seven so to to
to further answer your question my
understanding is that there is still
today supply chain issues with regards
to building accessing building materials
that that is my understanding we that
that was an issue clearly that
manifested during covid I am personally
not a builder or a developer but that is
my understanding as to why this this
bill was
needed and I was going to make one more
comment I don't I don't it was one more
comment
um oh the other thing is
um again I'm not a builder or developer
but based on what what my understanding
is is with regards to our work our
Workforce we we don't have enough
workers to do the work that we need uh
um so I feel that that possibly also
factors into this the need for this bill
so that all being said if people feel
that some of these timelines need to be
adjusted I am open to suggestions and
amendments any other questions
representative
Kobe thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question um I noticed that
we're we're talking a lot about housing
um I don't see specifically and and I
don't have uh extensive planning board
experience like some of my colleagues
here I don't see that this is limited to
residential um
subdivisions thank you for the question
representative that would be uh well see
my understanding is that this would
pertain to all types of development
because planning boards um in
municipalities deal with commercial
residential so it would be
all so um followup if I may followup so
then we could potentially be looking at
a
10year
project um anywhere within a
municipality whether it be uh commercial
or residentially
zoned it depends on the the size and the
scope of the development project thank
you okay uh any other
questions see n thank representative
thank
you committee now calls uh Mr Eric power
please good morning again Mr
power good morning committee members Mr
Vice chair uh for the record I'm Eric
power from Brookline representing myself
in favor of this bill and uh current
planning serving on the planning board
since
2021 and um I think this is an important
bill um because I think right now we
have some timelines that are uh pretty
aggressive for some uh developments
especially housing developments
and the um what happens is that
sometimes if they take too long they
don't complete the development in five
years then they've got to go back and
get
reapprovals amendments over the past
five years and that can be a very
expensive process one of the things that
happened recently um was the uh was the
pandemic we had supply chain we had
workers we had a lot of shutdowns so um
a lot of the um subdivision plats that
were approved in the 2020 2021 they
languished and um they needed they're
running up against the five-year um time
clock that's currently in
law when developers take on projects
they they aren't looking for delays
they're doing the projects to make money
so they're always trying to make things
happen as fast as they can because
that's the goal and so they're not
intentionally going to
um slow down a
project however um there sometimes are
circumstances beyond their control
things that come up with maybe surprises
during the development and those have to
be dealt with and that does cause delays
the other thing that you got to consider
is sometimes a developer is looking at
they look at these timelines and they
make a a decision how big a project do I
want to take on I know I have to finish
I have to get it substantially underway
in two years and I have to complete
complet it in five wow I might not want
to do as big a project because you know
there's a big risk there that I'm going
have to be 80% done and I'm going to
have to come back to the planning board
and go through this whole approval
process again and they don't want to do
that so they may shy away from the
larger projects which is obviously not
something that we want in New Hampshire
right now especially from the housing
perspective so giving them that
flexibility of the extra two years um to
give them seven years to complete the
project and give them three years to get
substantial um substantial development
uh active and substantial development
underway makes a lot of sense the other
thing that we're doing in Brookline is
that we're we are growing like many
towns are and we had a growth management
ordinance for a while and the planning
board every year if you're not sure what
a growth management ordinance is it it
allows you to limit how many building
permits you have a year we had that in
place and this year we had made a
calculation say you know this this
growth of management ordinance is good
but it's a little heavy-handed it was
limiting the number of building permits
to about you know 15 in our town for the
whole year and we said well that doesn't
make sense but we didn't want to open up
the floodgates completely so we ended up
um develop adopting something that was
allowed under land use law we've
proposed it it's on our ballot uh next
week to adopt phase development where we
can phase things for up to five
years and um I hope the voters approve
it it's been had had positive public
hearing but you can see where this is
going so now we have a phase development
that we're going to be probably adopting
in our
town and so they're going to have to hit
the hit their numbers almost exactly
because we're going to have this
five-year phase development which is
what's allowed under law and now they
only have five years to complete it so
the intent is to phase the development
because we have some school capacity
challenges and we want to be able to
manage that and and and grow the schools
and not be
overcrowded um and also for municipal
Services as well so by by allowing the
seven years that makes things work a lot
better and um it allows us as as a
planning board to have this phase
development work as well this is a
something that's happening across the
state um summer doing the phase
development some are not but I think
having when you when you're allowed to
do a phase development for five years it
makes sense to give seven years to
complete a project because because life
happens during these
projects um I also think the correction
of the Zoning Board of adjustment
requiring it now to be your building
cold board of appeals that has to be an
elected doesn't make sense a lot of um
towns have an appointed zoning Board of
adjustments so they should be able to
act in that that case and I also think
the changes about the whole appeals
process makes a lot of sense we don't
need our local Zoning Board of
adjustment hearing an appeal on a fire
marshal code that is set by the state or
State Building Code set by the state not
locally changed but set by the state it
makes sense for that to be heard by the
state at the state level um and do that
more expediently and that will also
speed things up and so for those reasons
I would recommend passage of HB 4113 I
hope you recommended OTP out of
committee and I'll take any
questions thank you Mr power how about
questions represent
stavis thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you for taking my question um is it your
understanding that a de developer has to
com completely go through the review
process of the planning board again to
be granted a two-year extension
they don't have to go thank you for the
question they don't have to go through
that the planning board can do that but
there's always the risk that uh
depending on who's on the planning board
and what's going on they have no
guarantees and this would give them a
guarantee followup Mr yeah go ahead
followup but currently under law that is
not a requirement full planning Board
review for a two-year extension that is
not that is correct thank you any other
questions representive
awood thank you Mr Vice chairman and
thank you Mr power for taking my
question on page three of the side by
side item
eight um regarding 155 d a colon
11-b the amended language Roman
1 the board shall hear and decide
appeals of order ERS decisions or
determinations made by the local
building official shouldn't it say
building code
official I building official
doesn't tell
me what this official
does thank you for the question I would
I'm not sure if that's correct or not
I'm I'm it might be correct or you might
need to have the word code in there have
to look and see how it's referenced in
the RSA but would be a minor fix if it
need needed to be there we want to have
it correct obviously so thank you for
bringing that up thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you Mr power
thank
you Comm you a call Mr bro Dees
please good morning again Mr
desas thank you Mr Vice chairman uh for
the record my name is bro Dees I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and we are currently opposed
to House Bill
413 as um as it's as it's written um the
proposed vesting periods to my
understanding were negotiated by my
predecessor and the New Hampshire
planners Association agreeing Upon A
seven-year vesting period with a
three-year extension the three-year
extension being if uh granted by the
planning board we do want to raise some
concerns with page two lines 18- 22 um
this would essentially bypass the local
building code board of appeals either a
zoning Board of adjustments or the board
of Selectmen for almost every single
building code appeal under RSA 674 colon
34 um the vast majority of
municipalities don't substantively amend
their local building code so rarely
would they ever hear an appeals
additionally it can be more practical um
to the property owner Builder code
enforcement officer Andor fire chief to
attend a buildin code appeals hearing in
their municipality versus going to
conquered for a hearing um limiting to
limiting to only local appeals on local
amendments to the building code cuts out
key sto stakeholders including the
municipality and doesn't necessarily
make the process easier arguably it may
slow down the process and could do so
substantively for developers having to
wait you know I'm unsure how often the
um the State Building Code appeals board
the State Building board meets but um
you'd be on their timetable rather than
the municipality maybe getting on their
horse and trying to schedule something
as soon as reasonably possible again we
aren't opposed to increasing the vesting
period to uh to 7 over three years or
increasing the extension period from 24
months to 3 years but making that
requirement retroactive to July 1st 2023
invites unanswerable questions on
entitlement to statutory vesting for
example what if a me so specifically
this is page two lines 13- 14 um this
retroactive imposing of the change of
vesting and some questions we might ask
would be what if a municipality has
already ruled a project lost its vesting
and legal cases closed does this now
allow reopening of the case there's some
ambiguity and uncertainty there um does
this violate the State Constitution
which prevents retroactive laws could a
municipality have standing if this law
negatively impacts their residents or
the town's government um we do want to
flag too that when uh these um these
vesting periods were previous previously
changed last done in 2011 uh SB 144 um
they made similar changes but did not
make them
retroactively so um we would we would
kindly ask that the um the committee at
at bare minimum consider um not making
these vesting period changes
retroactive um and with that I thank you
for taking my testimony this morning and
I'll take any
questions thank you Mr Des any
questions representative
Kobe thank you Vice chair thank you for
taking my question
um what are some of the costs whether
they be monetary or
um you know other uh that are born by
municipalities uh associated with
lengthy
development are you talking about like
uh like traffic or um Road damages or
improvements or other projects like what
are some of the the costs associated
with lengthy
development if you're talking about
long-term phase developments I mean
there's a there's a lot of cost yeah as
as I mean any kind of higher density
housing developments that are going to
be established in municipality there's
going to be there's going to be cost to
to infrastructure whether it's water and
sewer there's going to be cost to the
environment possibly because of the
increase of waste disposal and limiting
the amount of land that's um that's been
preserved you know for for natural use
um you're going to see um you know more
wear and tear on your roads you're going
to need more plows possibly more police
and fire to meet those needs depending
on the size of development you might
need to hire you know hire more
Municipal staff and more Public Safety
staff I mean all all development because
populations increase and because it's
the nature of the Beast is going to
require more tax money more revenues and
more of those revenues to be allocated
to dealing with higher populations in
larger municipalities I mean it's like
the difference between you know I know
enfield's a smaller town representative
Frack than wolfboro so it's like the
difference between what Enfield might
need versus if it grew up to the size of
wolfboro versus if wolf bro became the
size of Manchester right the amount of
resources and the amount of um
infrastructure you need to support that
type of development or those types of
municipalities they vary greatly and
they're very dictated by population and
population is dictated by the housing
Supply and how much housing you might
have uh you know per you know per
acre repr maor thank you Mr Vice
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I'm I'm wrapping up 12 years on
the planning board so hopefully these
issues will be behind me a little bit
but in those 12 years we've approved a
lot of plans that have been contentious
and we we weigh the value of a Butter's
rights very heavily in every case that
we have by extending the period to 73 or
whatever it might be do you consider
there to be an extended imposition on a
Butters which is not being considered in
this
bill I think in some respects yes and
obviously over a 7-year period
municipalities can change greatly and um
the circumstances or the traffic
patterns of that property where the
development's planned it can also change
greatly and so you know uh I think the
goal of this bill is to try to balance
the needs of developers to have some
stability in the process um as they're
trying to get financing and as they're
trying to get their development going
with the needs for municipalities and
ultimately those they represent such as
a Butters to be able to um to require
them to go back through the planning
process should they um should they go
past the seven-year period as proposed
so um I mean I do hear the concerns and
um there are concerns that we share at
the municipal
Association any other
questions is seeing none thank you Mr
Des thank
you that was also the last speaker for
HB 413 that I have a card for does
anyone else want to give testimony
concerning that
bill okay I don't see any the blue sheet
please
representative Gilman could you uh
please report uh the blue sheet please
the remote testimony showed for in
support and to oppose
and the paper blue sheet shows one in
favor thank you representative now close
the hearing on HB 413
right
at this time I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 229 local
repealing the alternative procedure for
adoption of zoning
ordinances the chair recognizes
representative kazinski to introduce the
bill to the committee thank you
representative thank you Madam chair for
the record my name is Sly
Kosinski and representing chesher
district
10 House Bill 229 local this bill
repeals The Authority for non-charter
towns Villages districts or other or
counties with unincorporated places to
adopt zoning ordinances through
alternative
procedures thank you
Representative
no at this time the chair recognizes Mr
Eric
power good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair
and committee members uh for the record
my name is Eric power from
Brookline um representing myself in
favor of this bill also uh serving on
the brooklane planning board since
2021 um this this bill is about um
looking at the alternative procedure for
the adoption of ordinances that was a
real that was originally uh in house in
Senate Bill 538 last year which was
voted itl by the house in a roll call
then that language was added as an
amendment to House Bill
1400 uh which ultimately became law um
what this procedure does it allows that
the uh the town can vote to let the
select board be the ones that propose
and approve zoning amendments in the
town by a simple majority vote at a
meeting after a single public hearing um
there are many problems created by this
law and House Bill 229 resends this um
this resends this procedure for many
reasons um
first this new law strips away a key
responsibility from local planning
boards that is proposing zoning
amendments it takes away the zoning
proposal Authority and responsibility
from the planning board and gives it to
the select board and it eliminates one
of the main functions of the planning
board it's the planning board that has
the knowledge training and expertise in
crafting and listening to our Town's
voters to develop zoning amendments in
accordance with with our master plan
zoning changes need to be made in a
careful deliberate manner with public
input and often multiple public hearings
after that input to not create
unintended consequences and create
conflicts in zoning ordinances the
select board has many other
responsibilities and typically lacks the
necessary background in zoning and and
in the time to properly carry out this
important
responsibility number two it
disenfranchises Town voters who no
longer vote on zoning amendments if you
have this alternative procedure it's the
select board deciding on the zoning
amendments they propose them and they
they vote on them the voters do not have
a say except for maybe a plea at a
public hearing this takes away A Long
established process of final approval of
zoning amendments on Election Day on
official ballot by voters and will
likely cause voter disenfranchisement
and resentment number three it further
concentrates power power and authority
in select
boards right now the zoning proposal
Authority resides with the planning
board or by citizens by citizens
petition while the approval is all the
town's voters by official ballot this
new law 6741 18a gives the Z select
board zoning Amendment exclusive
proposal and and approval Authority in
note this was proposed to help the
housing crisis but that this author is
not limited to residential zoning
amendments but applies as zoning
amendments for commercial and Industrial
zones as well and if you think about it
in a in a town with a five-person select
board three members can propose and
approve zoning amendments in towns with
just three Selectmen you can have two
members that entirely propose and
approve zoning amendments for the entire
town most would believe this is a undo
and unhealthy concentration of P of
zoning power in just a few
individuals and number four
this this law has created numerous
conflicts and ambiguities in lanu
statute um the bill talks about
redefining the the the the law redefines
the governing
body as the legislated body for the
purpose of zoning amendments but it
fails to make adjustments in many other
areas of land use statute and I have
them in the hand out I'll just highlight
a couple of them in RSA
3753 it talks about the method of
enactment of zoning amendments there's a
you know statement there saying it'll be
amendments are upon the affirmative vote
of the ballot of the majority of legal
voters there's a conflict because only
the selectman vote on approving
amendments is not voted at the town
meeting um paragraph four of that RSA
talks about you know having if there's a
public hearing and there's substanti of
changes made by made by the uh planning
board after that hearing they will hold
another hearing ing that doesn't apply
to the select board they can do one
hearing and and they don't require to
have a second one if changes were made
so that is a problem number uh RSA 6754
is about zoning petition warn articles
by citizens how are those handled if you
adopt this legislation um it says that
25 or more voters can petition a zoning
ordinance and that petition amendments
can only be voted on at the annual or V
Village district meeting via the
official ballot so what happens there
there's a conflict with the alternative
zoning procedure that only Selectmen can
propose amendments not citizens and
these are not voted on upon a town
meeting and then RSA 6755 is about
zoning protest zoning ordinance protest
petitions when when citizens can uh get
together and protest a zoning amendment
that has to be done at the annual
meeting seven days ahead and it requires
a 2/3 this is an example of a 2/3 vote
2third of the me members of the
legislative body shall vote to resend or
change via a a zoning protest petition
well with this new law does that mean
that the legislative body now being the
Selectmen is it just two-thirds of the
Selectmen and do they do that at the
town meeting very unclear so you can see
these conflicts in statute if if this if
this enabl uh this enabling legislation
is adopted would create some legal
problems and lastly the legislation so
called enabling legislation is enabling
legislation that can't be rescinded
there's only a provision to adopt this
legislation so once you adopt it there's
no way to resend it and I don't think
that's a good thing every every enabling
legis almost every leg enabling
legislation in the state has a provision
for resending um a once adopted for
example if you adopt sb2 you can resend
it if you adopt a local tax cap you can
resend it this has no resend mechanism
so once you voted put it in you've got
it forever that's not a good thing so
for these reasons I think that this this
this this new law needs to be repealed
and I would recommend a to pass on House
Bill 229 and I'll take any questions
thank you are there questions for the
speaker representative majori is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um last year I was one of a
number of people in the house uh who's a
selectman who serves on a planning board
jumping up and down that passing uh 1400
and 538 with this in it was an
absolutely horrible idea horrible idea
even as a member I don't want the
responsibility to do this and a lot of
people feel the same a lot of of my
colleagues felt the same way but the
sponsor isn't here to introduce this
bill and we have a longstanding well we
have a we have a a tradition well I
don't know what the right word is but a
lot of times we itl the bill so here's
my question do you believe this language
could be amended it onto another bill so
that we could pass it and it would be
then
valuable well if a uh thank you for the
question if if a co-sponsor was here to
testify on that would that fulfill that
requirement may may I respond Madam
chair woman yeah yes you may I thought
that would have been great
further
questions seeing none thank
you so that's the last pink card that I
have for this bill is there anyone
present who wishes to speak to this bill
who has not yet had the opportunity to
do so seeing none the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report out the
blue sheets uh thank you madam chair on
the remote sign in there are two in
support and three opposed
and M Madam chair the blue sheet is
blank thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing on house build
local
e
e e
okay I'm going to open up the hearing on
HB 372 local which is relative to lease
agreements of equipment for buildings or
facility
improvements uh first speaker is uh
representative Diane power uh We've also
just before we start with representative
power we've got quite a few speakers uh
so please don't try to repeat other
things that folks have said and if we
could limit your testimony to uh 3
minutes thank you uh go ahead
representative power thank you Mr
chairman and honorable committee members
as the prime sponsor I appreciate the
opportunity to introduce to you today
House Bill 372 local for the record I am
representative Diane power I represent
the towns of Brooklyn Mason and
Greenville in Hillsboro County District
36 this bill is a refiling of 2024 House
Bill 1187 which passed the house on the
consent calendar with a unanimous
committee recommendation of ought to
pass with Amendment the bill then passed
the other body and unfortunately was a
vetoed by the governor and subsequently
it failed a veto override in
October um I believe it was veto due to
a misunder understanding of the
legislation this is a simple
straightforward bill that was filed due
to the widespread misuse of the statute
of lease agreements of equipment RSA 33
col
7-e under current law towns and school
districts across the state are proposing
Capital Improvement projects funded by
extremely high cost long-term lease
agreements with e for of equipment with
Escape Clauses leasing for these fixture
based capital
projects is being used as a financing
approach because such proposals
currently qualify under RSA 33 7-e
enabling easier approval of the lease by
a simple majority vote at an annual
meeting in addition such leases under
the statute are not classified as
long-term debt to qualify under this
statute a least with an escape Clause is
required which typically has an interest
rate of 1 to 2% higher than a comparable
Bond making it much more expensive than
Bond financing the problem addressed by
this bill is the closing of a loophole
in current law that allows for the lease
of items that once installed become
fixtures such as building materials like
framing Drive wall insulation flooring
doors windows electrical lighting HVAC
Etc under a lease agreement with an
escape clause and this presumes that
these items once installed can be
returned so I would ask you to ask
yourself how can something that's fixed
and installed a fixed and installed
piece of
equipment and building materials
returned once it's
installed in my opinion and the opinion
of others this is a clear misuse of the
lease agreements of equipment statute
moreover based on my ongoing research
and reports from State reps across the
state and citizens as well I have now
found 24 examples to date of school
districts and towns misusing the lease
agreements of equipment statute and I've
provided those examples to you in this
handout for your reference so I'll point
out a a couple of examples in 2022 the
Brookline district school district put
forth a warrant article for an 18-year
lease agreement with an escape Clause
totaling $2.5 million for energy
conservation equipment an elevator
security improvements as well as
classroom
Renovations and in 2024 for the Thornton
School District put forward a warrant
article for a 20-year lease agreement
with an escape clause for a total Boiler
Room
replacement costing $4.4 million the
most egregious misuse of this lease
agreements of equipment statute was in
2023 in which the Timberlane Regional
School District placed a an a war an
article on the warrant to fund a 20year
lease agreement totaling
$25.2 million for facilities repairs and
maintenance at multiple schools it's
been estimated that the lease in this
particular case will end up costing the
taxpayers more than $6 million more in
interest payments than if a bond had
been
used so again stop and ask yourself how
is a lease agreement with an escape
Clause practical in any of these cases
and also how could you even escape a
least renovation taxpayers should not
have to pay a premium lease interest
rate for a lease within Escape Clause
that can't be practically exercised so
the solution is House Bill
372 which ends the misuse of this
statute lease agreements of equipment
with Escape clauses it closes the loose
loophole that's being inappropriately
used to fund major facilities
improvements and Renovations around the
lease of
equipment and it also prevents items or
equipment that become fixed items or
fixtures to be financed through lease
agreements of equipment under the
statute to be clear House Bill 372 still
allows for any lease agreement of
equipment to be proposed and adopted but
it does not allow for the lease
agreement of equipment that contains
items that once installed become
fixtures under RSA 33 col 7-e so items
that are not fixtures like vehicles and
wheeled items are still supported by
this statute under this
bill and I need to address one important
thing and that is to point out that you
will hear other people testify and claim
that certain types of projects such as
energy improvements and Renewables will
be negatively impact impacted or even
prohibited by this bill and this simply
is not true to be clear under house bill
372 these projects in fact can still be
proposed and financed by a bond or lease
agreement under our RSA 32 and
33 this includes energy performance
contracts which fall under RSA
21i colon
19d importantly because these types of
lease agreements will no longer qualify
under
337e due to containing equipment that
become fixtures these lease agreements
now need to be approved by a 35th
majority vote and if they're approved it
will be considered long term
debt after all these leases are really
long-term commitments with no practical
or economical means by which to escape
and return
fixtures House Bill 372 will encourage
School boards and select boards to use
the most coste effective method um
financing method um to finance projects
on behalf of the taxpayers which will
undoubtedly in most cases
it it's bonds and leases without these
expensive Escape Clauses so for these
reasons I ask that the committee
recommend ought to pass on House Bill
372 local to bring an end to the misuse
of lease agreements of equipment statute
thank you Mr chairman and I'm happy to
take
questions thank you representative power
uh any questions to the
representative representative
kobby thank you Vice chair thank you for
taking my question um I noticed there's
no description for the term
fixtures um in many municipalities and
school districts uh we would lease um
things like software um or network
upgrades uh we would lease security
cameras security
systems um at what point is something
thing to me that becomes a fixture of
the building so how are we separating
the
project thank you for the question
representative to be clear like I said
this is a refiling of a bill from last
um last legislative session and the bill
as introduced was huge it was very much
different and I worked very closely with
the New Hampshire Municipal
Association um we went through many
reiterations of this bill to arrive at
the language that is in front of you and
my understanding so obviously I work
very closely with the financial
um person at nhma as well as the
municipal
attorney to um distill the language to
what we have and my understanding is
that fixture is a well-defined term
legally so um to expound and
so to expound on that a fixture is
something that once installed is is
permanent and becomes part of the
building the
plant things that items that are
equipment is something that is a
standalone if you will like this statute
337e lease agreements of
equipment the purpose of the legislative
intent of that of that statute is for
leases with Escape closet for items that
are return that can be returned for
example like a fire trck an ambulance a
piece of heavy equipment maybe a copier
uh or even possibly a generator that
sits outside on a pad those are things
that can easily be returned and as I
described in my bill
introduction and if you refer to this
handout you'll see descriptions of
projects that are being proposed that go
well
beyond uh the definition of equipment as
I said we're talking about flooring
drywall Windows
Etc an
elevator you going to rip out the
elevator and return it that just doesn't
make sense so I hope that helps to
clarify your
question repr kobby uh just a quick
followup
so if I have a police department that
leases their cameras and their security
equipment and maybe the servers that go
along with those I've built a special
room for that
server I have done special wiring uh and
electrical um that may or may not be a
part of the lease
agreement uh do do I have to separate
those two items now if this legislation
were to pass would I have to in other
words pay a separate
electrician um and and hire uh separate
entities and then have the equipment
installed
by the company that was leasing to me
that that would be correct
because I hope that people can
understand that the statute is being
abused so to go back to my example of a
generator that's a piece of equipment
and the statute as written you could you
could roll in the cabling maybe the
concrete for the pad I mean that's
that's fine but we're talking about
multi-million dollar projects that that
are being
um funded through this statute and
that's just that that's gone Way Beyond
as as I said that the statute the
legislative intent of the statute is
being misused used and it's incumbent
upon the legislature to recognize that
and to address that on behalf of the
taxpayers any other
questions seeing none thank you
representative thank
you our next speaker will be Natasha
Shaw
good morning
ma'am good morning hope everyone's doing
well um thank you madam chair and The
Honorable members of this committee uh
my name is Natasha Shaw and I'm opposing
this house bill 372 on behalf of the
National Association of energy service
companies um we're also called Nasco so
Nasco is a leading trade Association for
industry Energy Services IND indry and
our concerted efforts have been
dedicated to the advocacy promotion for
Energy savings performance contracts um
our industry has successfully executed
over 7 billion annually so I'm a little
bit surprised um uh by the comments by
the sponsor um we've been doing these
projects nationally through lease
agreements um it's a very well-respected
program there were some comments made
about uh misuse and Escape clauses is I
just want to be clear that uh you know
the common law in New Hampshire
overwrites the needs for the scape
Clause um the bill significantly
restricts our customers Cy City Schools
from implementing infrastructure and
building improvements through these tax
exempt lease agreements and this
financing V vehicle does not require any
taxpayer dollars this bill is frankly
catastrophic and terrible for our local
related businesses and unworkable for
many of our communities the true
intended consequence of this bill is
that it prevents local government from
addressing deferred maintenance and
critical Capital infrastructure needs
through lease agreements resulting in
the need to then spend money on costly
new construction lease Agreements are
one tool in the toolbox for
municipalities and this legislation
would further limit local government's
ability to properly maintain and sustain
their
infrastructure similar legislation as
mentioned by the sponsor was filed last
year and was ultimately vetoed by
governor sonunu in his veto message he
stated the offered legislation would
without exception undercut
municipalities opportunity to explore
such agreements in search of
advantageous timing and financing terms
municipalities have ever evolving needs
from school boilers to Energy Efficiency
projects that must be secured more
frequently than bonding opportunities
permit these decisions must still go
through multiple layers of approval
offering the opportunity for public
input and as such this B bill would
unnecessarily tie the hands of our local
communities I want to point out that we
have Karen ramaki she's with the state
of New Hampshire the state also does a
tremendous amount of these kind of
projects and if you guys would like as
an expert or subject matter expert for
her to answer any questions I want to
point out she's in the audience um and
she represents her official title is um
hang on one second uh director of State
of New Hampshire Department
administrative services division of
plant and property so I just want to
point that out she's here to answer any
questions so for those reasons we
strongly urge you to recommend itl on
House Bill 372 I'm welcome to answer any
questions you might
have thank you any
questions yes
weide thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you Miss Shaw for taking my question um
I I know you're talking about the leases
have been very helpful to communities my
question for you is based upon you're
saying that bonds may not be able to be
used your leases are not being done at
zero interest I'm presuming over that 20
years no they're not done at zero
interest over the 20 years and yes there
is um interest rates you know based on
what the market dictates that are are
used for these projects but the reality
is is that if there is an opportunity
for us to use Energy savings to fund
these improvements the goal is to not is
to make these local communities whole so
if they're paying $100 a month on
utilities and we bring it down to 90
they're using that $10 difference to pay
for the principal and interest of that
project over that 20-year term so our
goal is not for them to pay anything out
of pocket the goal is to reduce enough
energy savings so that they can then use
that money towards that infrastructure
Improvement does that make sense sir
thank you
Micha any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for
coming in thank
you the committee We Now call uh Mr Eric
power
please thank you committee members um Mr
chair for the record my name is Eric
power um resident of Brookline also ser
on the brooklane planning board since
2021 speaking in favor of this bill uh
this bill is really needed because I
think taxpayers are getting uh way
overpaying for projects in in New
Hampshire especially school districts
but also some towns
um when you do these lease agreements
with Escape Clauses they were really
meant to be done with for vehicles and
wheel vehicles and such like a fire
truck like a DPW vehicle like a police
cruiser and that's being done frequently
and being done again this year every
year because the vehicle can be easily
returned the vehicle can um be returned
without penalty and that's why you have
the Escape Clause but when you have
these lease agreements that are being
used to fund Renovations and energy
contracts it's it's not the proper
mechanism it's very expensive
the this just this year our Hollis
Brooklyn Co-op School District looked at
doing a 5.3
million lease with Escape Clause of for
some boilers and energy saving equipment
and we pressed them and said why are you
doing this can't you do a bond and they
actually re relented after we got after
them and and they finally changed their
mind and we found that a a bond rate was
3.84%
and a lease for that same project was
5.45% so it was over 1.6% higher and we
had them calculate the budget committee
calculated that the just the interest
only difference was 1.4 million for the
lease so why should the taxpayers pay
$1.4 million for a lease agreement with
an escape clause which you can't escape
we're not going to pull out the boilers
we're not going to pull out the LED
lighting it doesn't make any sense
you know it's well known in law that
that a fixture is an asset that's
installed or otherwise fixed into a
building or land so that it becomes part
of the
building and that's uh that's that's
that's the normal legal definition for
it um the other thing that this bill
does it it this only this is a narrow
exemption case for lease agreements of
equipment if you don't fall under this
then you fall under RSA 32 327 and RSA
33 so this in no way prevents lease
agreements lease agreements can still be
done lease Agreements are still possible
this is a special case of a lease
agreement that is a carve out but if
lease Agreements are still wanted they
can still be done and they can compete
with bonds the the main reason that
lease Agreements are being used in this
case is that it gives two advantages
which are really at a very high taxpayer
expense number one it's not considered
long-term debt but number two these leas
Agreements are being passed at a simple
majority vote and it's not even a ballot
vote in a traditional meeting it's just
a card vote so you're spending millions
of dollars on a simple majority for
these lease agreements that are 10 15 or
20 years
long and taxpayers are way
overpaying for a uh a project for these
leases leases are still possible this
does not stop leases leases can still
happen so if you have an energy
performance contract it will likely need
a three-fifth majority it will still
happen it will not pass with a simple
majority that's the only real difference
here and I think that that taxpayers
should not have to pay more for the
benefit of having a simple majority to
pass it it makes no sense so that's I
think that's the big rub here and you
know I think that that this law will
close the loophole and that lease
agreements will comp will compete with
bonds and other mechanisms on the same
footing and not having this advantage of
the simple majority to pass them into
law so for those reasons and to stop the
abuse of taxpayers across the state I
hope that you find uh you recommend a to
pass on House Bill 372 and I'm willing
to take any
questions thank you Mr power any
questions representative
kobby thank you chair thank thank you
for taking my question
um is there a
difference uh in a credit rating of a
community or a school
district when a bond is utilized versus
a lease is
there there's the credit rating is based
on the the history of the um and the
amount of debt that the school district
or the town takes on so it's a function
of that if you do the lease agreement
that qualifies under this Clause it it
is not considered long-term debt because
it follows those those those those
stages but if you do it outside of this
Clause it is considered long-term debt
because the statement that it's not
long-term debt is part of RSA
337e representative
Dolan thank you Vice chair um if
a community in an energy savings
environment decided they wanted to
replace a Windows for example in a
school um and they later decided they
wanted to return that those windows how
do you do
that that's a very good question
representative Dolan the um thank you
for the question the you it's can you
return a window that's been installed of
course you can is it practical and what
are you going to replace it with that's
the whole that's the whole capricious
argument here is when something becomes
a
fixture can it be returns maybe but it's
at Great expense it's not practically
it's not practical from an economic
perspective and so you really don't have
no one's going to want to vote to stop
in a lease when the cost to get out of
the lease is going to be more than
you're paying because you you with the
case of a boiler you can't take the
boiler out out and not replace it you
can't take a window out and not replace
it same thing with insulation it's just
the wrong mechanism to use a lease
agreement for fixtures and that's the
point of this law is to avoid that
problem so that
people so that school districs if they
have energy performance and they can if
they want to lease some equipment as a
question that was earlier they can lease
the equipment if it's easily returnable
doesn't become a fixture but the things
they're doing to support that equipment
to make it that that become fix
that should be done throughout an
operating budget or a separate warrant
article as a one-time expenditure
because you're not going to ever escape
that that's a sunk cost thank you for
the
question any other
questions seeing none thank you for
coming in sir thank
you okay committee like to ask Mr Tom D
Roa to come up please
thank
you thank you Mr chairman if it's okay
uh Mr Mike Davy here has filled out a
pin card as well we're both uh on behalf
of eei so I thought it' be all right if
we came up together of course thank you
so uh for the record my name is Tom do
Roa principal at Main Street strategic
uh I represent energy efficient
Investments uh company out of
meramac um Mike Davey I'm an owner of
energy efficient Investments I live in
Manchester and we employ 7 72 employees
uh headquartered in
marac so we are here today in opposition
to this bill um as the prime sponsor
mentioned yes it was a refile from last
year uh we we caught it when it crossed
over to the other uh body um uh and have
some significant issues with it that
that remain at this point um the the one
of the biggest concerns I would say that
that we have with the the bill is uh
some of this has been brought up a
little bit here but you're taking away a
widget from the free market right
municipalities have the opportunity to
bond or lease these projects and if you
remove the ability to
lease uh then you're now forcing uh
municipalities into bonding and there
will be opportunities when bonds are
better there will be opportunities when
leases are better but at the end of the
day if you remove one of those options
that cost is shifted down to the
taxpayer and that is um certainly
something that we all know is uh
property taxes are an issue in the state
right and we all uh thank you all for
the work that you've done to help bring
property tax relief over the past few
sessions to homeowners uh but we see
this as something that would uh
certainly kind of shift that cost down
we also had a couple of legal opinions
that were done last year um regarding
some of this so if it's all right I'll
just quickly read some things um that uh
a couple of attorneys had put together
for us one thing on common law right so
common law defines what a fixture is uh
that establishes a fixture but does not
dictate Pro the procedure for municipal
leases in the event of a
non-appropriation of funds that
procedure is dictated by the specific
language of of the municipal lease
agreement um and depending on that
language the control and lease agreement
the Lesser may have the option but not
the obligation to remove the collateral
in the event of non-payment although
removement of the collateral may be the
only uh remedy available but ultimately
lessor is not the municipalities bear
the risk that the funds will not be
appropriate for continued payment under
the lease um and then we see
this as
um just a costeffective way for state
and local governments to finance needed
improvements um to these buildings and
with those Energy savings that M
mentioned that are realized they can
help to offset some of that financing
costs the other piece to think about is
if we take away this option and there's
only bonding available and
municipalities and towns do not want to
use their bonding capacity for these
projects and we cannot uh maintain our
buildings we would be looking at decades
down the line or maybe sooner for some
communities where we're now having to
rebuild and put new buildings uh in
place of these build that we're not
effectively maintaining so for those
reasons uh we oppose the bill but I'll
let Mr Davy speak to some of the
projects and works that he's done around
this as well yeah thank you and a lot of
the questions that we're debating here
are the debates that usually happen in
local uh budget committees School boards
and select boards and so you might ask
if the interest rate could be higher
than what the New Hampshire Bond Bank
might offer why might a municipality
decide to do a lease well there's many
advantages to a lease and we've had
generally our more conservative ative
towns choose the leasing option so for
example Lisbon uh Jaffrey ringe um
Woodsville considered leasing their
boiler uh for the middle school and
Candia budget committee unanimously
decided to to go with a lease rather
than a bond the reason being um you can
pay it off early so generally you your
debt you carry with you if you do a
20-year Bond you need to carry it uh
leasing allows you to negotiate early
payments uh we recently had a a district
that wanted to make extra payments in
years that they have a surplus so under
that scenario where maybe the interest
rate is a bit higher in 20 years you
might pay a bit more in interest a lot
of those um school districts and towns
um decide to make extra payments from
increased savings and efficiency and pay
these leases off earlier um in the other
um thing is we have declining enrollment
in many rural parts of the state for
schools and what the Escape Clause
allows you to do
is if you were to ever close a school
because you're going to redistrict the
students it's much easier and and in um
New Mexico there were many um districts
that had used the lease option and then
they were able to um sell the building
the lease went with the sale where bonds
typically you have to carry for the
entire 20-year debt so for that reason
when the city of Franklin acquired um
they had a school close the city
acquired um the r School turned it into
a community center and they did a lease
purchase agreement in a very
conservative town uh they thought that
was the best option for them to retrofit
that building and they turned it into a
senior center they also that same body
um used a uh a lease format in Franklin
to upgrade uh the city hall boiler they
wanted to preserve their bonding
capacity for other capital projects and
wanted to use a lease with Energy
savings to pay for it similarly the city
of nasua we just completed a $7 million
tax neutral energy lease to North and
South High School they needed their
bonding capacity for um projects that
were um uh planned for renovating the
middle school and doing an addition uh
Manchester also has a huge amount of its
capital tied up in a major um uh water
sewer separation project and also um the
the school Beach Street school project
so Manchester is looking at leasing to
do the boiler upgrades the city of
Portsmouth did a major uh Wastewater
project they're also so that tied up
their bonding capacity and so leases is
the way to upgrade your boilers upgrade
your HVAC system uh with the lowest tax
impact and unlike a bond it can be paid
off early and you can not um negotiate
flexible
payments okay any questions for the uh
gentleman thank you thank you for coming
in uh Mr Brendan flarity please
good morning Mr
FL good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee thank you uh my name is
Brendan flarey I'm with the DuPont group
and I here today on behalf of siries um
who's a nonprofit advocacy organization
um with a lot of businesses here in New
Hampshire um and I'm here today um to
speak in opposition to House Bill uh
372 and our opposition kind of broadly
falls into two categories uh real
quickly uh it uh uh government
efficiency and control and
infrastructure um development and
investment um and I think as Mr D Ro's
testimony uh pointed out uh HB
372 um undermines local control and
flexibility um it imposes kind of an
unnecessary uh state level restriction
with that 3- fifths uh majority vote um
to enter into lease agreements um and
that in turn makes government less
efficient um it prevents municipalities
and schools from implementing those
important Capital uh improvements um and
uh addressing delayed maintenance of
critical
infrastructure um and series uh sees
that as an unnecessary prohibition uh
the second part of our opposition um
around infrastructure and Energy
Efficiency Investments um we also view
this bill uh as a hindrance to um
developing that infrastructure and we
were recommend um itl um to ensure that
Municipal governments have the options
they need uh to finance critical
infrastructure Investments um and
finally on the uh Energy Efficiency side
um series uh is supportive of Energy
Efficiency and uh projects wherever they
can uh get them so um again 372 is a uh
a hindrance on those efforts as well at
the municipal level so with that I'm
happy to take any
questions thank you so any questions
see none thank you for coming in
sir our next speaker uh Lori Lane
please m m
Lan is it it's when it's red awesome I
haven't done this for a while um thank
you thank you for having having me this
morning uh my name is Lori Lane and I am
the superintendent of schools for the
Pittsfield school district and I'm here
to today to ask you to oppose HB
372 this bill seeks to amend RSA 33 col
7-e which currently allows a governing
body such as a local school board the
authority to enter into lease agreements
as a funding source for various types of
equipment including equipment purchased
as part of a building a building bus and
Facilities improvements and
Renovations the proposed Bill seeks to
change the RSA by preventing school
boards and municipalities from being
able to finance the purchase of
equipment that becomes a fixture and
that's in quotes because there's that's
one of the changes in the in the
legislation in a building with any kind
of lease agreements including Energy
Efficiency focused performance lease
agreements I'm asking you to oppose this
bill because it's unclear to me why the
legislature wants to limit the option
for school boards and communities on how
they choose to fund Capital Improvements
to their schools performance lease
agreements allow school districts
another option besides raising taxes and
taking out long-term bonds to fund
projects to keep their school building
safe for Learning and working in a state
that Prides itself on local control and
local decision making I find it puzzling
that the legislature would want to limit
the local a local community's ability to
make its own funding decisions entering
into a performance lease agreement to
pay for necessary HVAC equipment boiler
plant Replacements and lighting
equipment upgrades will result in
increased Energy Efficiency while at the
same time allow school districts to save
tens of thousands of dollars in
operating costs each year depending on
the scope of the capital Improvement
project performance lease agreements can
be can make these projects cost neutral
for school districts for example when I
worked in the summersworth school
district the school board approved
entering into two different cost neutral
performance leases one for a schoolwide
HVAC system and the other for
districtwide lighting retrofit project
the performance lease annual payments
for these projects were entirely offset
by the Energy savings the district
experienced there were no new taxes
raised to pay for either of these
projects in closing school boards and
communities have many challenges as they
look for ways to manage the rising costs
of aging and energy inefficient
buildings losing the performance lease
option would significantly hamper School
District's ability to address aging
infrastructure and inefficiencies in a
cost effective way and with that in mind
I ask you to oppose HP 372 I thank you
you for your
consideration thank you Miss lean uh
questions representative Comey thank you
Vice chair and thank you for taking my
question um and not sure how long you've
been a educator but we greatly
appreciate you gray hair a long time 35
years ma'am wow all right then maybe you
can answer this question um what does it
look like
uh when and it was touched on a little
bit but what does it look like when a
bond
is taken out for a
project uh you might be 10 years into a
20-year
Bond and that school is
closed what happens to the other 10
years of bond
payments so a bond versus the lease
correct so my understanding is the bond
the debt remains so the districts need
to figure out how they're going to
continue to pay for that so you know and
whether it's closing a school it's or in
a partnership with another school
district so when I was in summersworth
Rollinsford also um was a part of that
SAU at one time and so there was
discussion about whether or not
Rollinsford would also be assuming some
of the debt when they return when they
remove their students from the school so
they have to continue to do that whereas
like you know as as you've heard another
testimony you know you can pay those
leases off um early which which is an
attractive option I mean I just hope we
don't limit what we try to do we schools
we we try to be very creative in what we
do and how we fund projects and our
unfortunately our buildings are getting
older and whether they you know get
repurposed for other things or they end
up you know serving
um you know school students in a
different capacity um you know I I just
feel it's it's important for us to be
able to cre be as creative as possible
and not have our opportunities limited I
think it's important for us to be very
transparent about what we're doing and
some of the comments I've heard that
that it kind of sounds like that's not
been the case um that's not the case you
know I feel like my my colleagues and I
do a do an excellent job of trying to
make sure that voters and the school
boards are very aware of what's what
we're asking for terrific thank you
you're
welcome any other
questions thank you ma'am for coming in
whoops I'm sorry oh representative
Walker thank you Mr Vice
chair leasing small dollar items baffles
me in I'm from Rochester in Rochester
when we have a budget I live in
Rochester so we have the capital side uh
the bonding side and we have a cash side
small items like this we would put a
cash reserve on it and pay it off we
wouldn't want to pay any interest rates
is whatever so we don't do small leasing
on building fixtures or anything like
that we use cash items we have two two
pots of money now as administrator
doesn't your District do that that sort
of thing have a cash side and a and a
bonding side well you have different
options to fund so one of the projects
that we did in summersworth was uh to we
had all these old so think about old
hotels these unit ventilators and they
were incredibly inefficient this project
was about a million dollars we took all
of those out and put in a ducted system
um this was in
2019 and so we didn't have uh a capital
improve like a like a reserve fund there
there was nothing we we got some we
leveraged funds from uh School building
Aid um and we got some from the city we
asked for uh funds to help support the
project but there there wasn't another
option and we were like how how could we
possibly do this and so in working with
you know eei was the company we worked
with as part of one of the
subcontractors with this project that we
were able to to say we're going to save
this amount money money in um in Energy
savings so we reduced the amount of um
energy costs for the school by like 25
26,000 and those that money went to
paying for the lease so that's the cost
neutral part I'm not sure I'm answering
your question but but that's how it
worked and so you know I think I think
schools have a responsibility to look at
all different options and you know
whether you can go to the city and ask
for um support whether it's through the
legislature whether it you know with um
and the the Department of Education to
get funds for you know School building
Aid I mean I think there's a lot of
different things but you know for some
communities a million dollars million
and a half I think it was that that HVAC
project was was a lot of money and so
this was how we chose to we chose to
make um to fund that project thank you
you're
welcome any other
questions seeing none thanks for coming
in
ma'am okay m said Dean and
Jenis Angelus I apologize
sir I'd like to thank the members of the
committee for uh having us speak today
uh I'm here to speak in opposition to HB
372 uh I work for Johnson Controls I am
the account executive uh that does uh
energy performance Contracting through
all of New England uh to make that short
that's Maine Vermont and New Hampshire
um some things I I I just want to point
out that I've heard throughout this
meeting uh we we we're hearing about
bonds we're hearing about tax exemp
purchases and what I've heard is that
apparently the tax assembly purchases
has a higher cost if we look at the
definition of an energy performance
contract the energy performance contract
is set up so that the Energy savings
that are guaranteed by the Esco the
Energy Services Company are there to
completely offset all costs for the
project um and that's the way we build
our projects and we do it in a in a
manner with all of our customers that is
100%
transparent um even down to markups and
and things of that nature so that our
customers understand how the costs are
allocated and how that tax is least
purchased is set up so that the Energy
savings are guaranteed to offset that
debt so whether you go to a bond and to
me a bond automatically means a tax
implication or whether you go to a tax
tax exemple purchase to me is a fiscal
it's a fiscal decision made by a a
committee at a school or a municipality
to say I want to put all my debt here
and have it completely offset by Energy
savings or if I'm going to use a bond
toay pay this off I'm going to be going
back to my taxpayers at some point for
possibly a increase in their taxes
that's something that we've always
fought to avoid uh in building these
projects they take a great deal of time
to put together um and there's a great
deal of information that's shared
between the Energy Services Company and
the customer so that when you get down
to final presentations and final
decision-making processes that
everything is above board um and I think
I've said this a million times to my
customers if I can prove it to you on
paper if I can show you the cash flow
and show you where the eyes are dotted
and the tees are cross and guarantee
that these savings will offset your debt
obligation is there any reason why you
wouldn't want to move forward with this
type of
arrangement I have a school system in uh
in uh New England uh where we have done
three phases of energy work energy
performance work uh over the last 10
years in 10 years we've reduced our
total energy spend to date by half
measured and verifiable which equates to
I believe just a little over $5 million
in the last 10 years that's a
pretty significant sum of money in a
small small town in New England um I
could say that uh to move forward with
this type of legislation is going to
restrict the ability of uh Energy
Services companies like uh my colleagues
and I sitting here today to come out and
uh prove prove that you know in each
instance we are trying to do the best
that we can to help municipalities small
municipalities medium municipalities
large municipalities make the most of
every budgetary dollar that they have I
don't look to go to my customers and
seek Capital funding for their projects
what I do is I go to my customers and
say what can I do to get you the things
that you need and fit it all into
something that is cost contained and
does not impact the tax implications for
your constituents
for those reasons I I would hope that uh
this AUST body would vote against HB
372 thank you sir
questions seeing then thanks for coming
in sir I appreciate it thank
you our last speaker
is Sam Evans Brown close
thank you members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Sam Evans
Brown I'm the executive director of
clean energy New Hampshire uh one of the
benefits of going last is I don't have a
great deal to add in addition to what
the folks who are real experts in this
have already stated um I would just say
clean energy New Hampshire as an
organization represents many of the
energy service companies uh that that
are here before you uh as as members of
our of our business membership but also
closing in I was actually looking at the
the little blurb on the back of Our
Testimony which needs updating we're
closing in on 50 municipalities in the
state of New Hampshire that we provide
technical assistance in in pursuing
clean energy projects in their own towns
and so we uh serve as sort of a uh you
know vendor neutral nonpartisan actor in
this space and I would just say there
are a great number of communities that
are using these Energy Services
Contracting lease arrangements to save
money for their taxpayers uh and just in
very simple terms I think that the
passage of this bill is going to result
in in higher expenses for uh New
Hampshire New Hampshire residents so I I
see it as a a problem in search of a
excuse me a solution in search of a
problem um which I think is exactly why
the governor vetoed this last year uh
just for a bit of legislative history I
think the reason that it got over to the
Senate it with uh a unanimous
recommendation is that most of us just
didn't notice it we missed it uh last
year uh and sort of swung into action
once we saw this bill uh and and
realized what it what it meant which is
why you're seeing such a um you know an
array of folks coming out to oppose it
today uh so uh with that said I will I
will let my written testimony speak for
itself um if folks have questions for me
I'm happy to answer them but I would
urge you to uh con you know recommend
this bill uh in expedient to
legislate thank you Mr Brown any
questions seeing none thanks for coming
in
sir okay that was the last pain card is
there anyone else in the audience that
would like to testify for or against the
bill you seeing
none when you're ready representative
Gilman
thank you Mr chair um for the remote
signin we had three in support of this
bill and uh 29 in
opposition and on the paper blue sheet
we had uh four in opposition and one uh
didn't didn't
indicate thank you representative I will
now close the hearing in HB 372 local
so with that that concludes our publicly
noticed hearings for today and before we
go to lunch um
no I don't have I don't have lunchtime
announcements so um we're going we're
going to take lunch and then we will
reconvene for executive sessions at
1:00 thank
you
e
e e
move into executive sessions and I do
apologize for the slightly delayed start
but the Republicans um decided to caucus
um on a
bill so um we have a lot of amendments
floating around and after lunch you
probably when you come came back
probably saw an explosion of paper had
your Des areas so I I will go slowly
through the executive session in order
to um allow enough time for the
committee members to sort themselves out
on each
bill so at this time I will open the
executive session on House Bill
569 relative to the establishment of
countywide communication districts
at this time I would like to offer
amendment
20255 61h to House Bill
569 so this amendment
um addresses feedback that we heard um
during the hearing and I worked with the
prime sponsor on this amendment and the
first thing that it does
is it added in governing bodies of
municipalities um into
that may include themselves in the the
this planning committee and also um
importantly the amended
language states that this shall be an op
in provision rather than an opt out
provision as the bill had been F that
seems to make um more sense and it also
provides that governing bodies of
municipalities can vote to join uh the
communications District planning
committee at a future time and um if the
communications District um is
established they may also vote to to
join at as well on the
future so is there a second
on well I I just I seriously messed up
okay all right I forgot that I was
supposed to offer this and then ask for
a second so let me back up so I'd like
to offer this amendment is there a
second represent Colby seconds it yes
okay so um I'm not I I don't need to
repeat my little explanation does
anybody else have anything that they
would like to um say with regards to the
amendment
representative
grund the one thing I'd like to say is
thank you for uh making an opt
in further com um representative Walker
yes just a
little uh typographical here you mention
it's in h uh tyze and bold or governing
bodies of a county should it say
governing bodies govern bodies of a
county in the other paragraph that's
being
changed because I was told by my County
Commissioners that a county is not a
municipality um yes that so just to be
clear it's governing bodies of two or
more municipalities that that that's the
language that's already in statute and
the whole purpose of the bill is that
the governing body of a county might
also initiate this study um um
committee so that was the whole purpose
of the bill so that's why that you see
both of those Provisions that two or
more municipalities may form a a
um the this Communications District
planning
committee or a second option would be
that the governing body of a county
meaning the Commissioners could
also stand up the planning
committee that was the whole premise of
the bill is to enable at the county
level this to be
done further questions or comments or
debate so the motion before us right now
is to accept Amendment 20255
5 61h to House Bill 569 if you are in
favor of accepting the amendment then
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
accepting the amendment then you will
vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes
the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grundt yes Madam
chair
yes so the vote being 18 to Z on
amendment
225-5618
is accepted
do I have a further do I have a motion
on the
bill representative Colby I'd like to
make a motion uh ought to pass as
amended do I have a
second representative stavis seconds
that would you like to speak to the bill
with Amendment sure um I think with the
amendment uh this bill will uh formally
allow municipalities and um counties to
engage in plan discussions uh for
purposes of pooling resources and uh
buying power to achieve common goals uh
in the areas of both broadband and
highspeed internet
access thank you is there any discussion
on the
motion okay seeing none the motion
before us is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill
569 if you are in favor of that motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan
yes representative
Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative Laurel excuse me
representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerna
yes representative Gerard yes represent
resentative grund yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 569 is ought to pass with
Amendment yeah I'm thinking
yeah I'm I'm trying to go slow so I
don't mess up so without objection that
that will go on to the consent
calendar and representative Colby would
you like to author the committee report
sure thank
you and with that the executive session
on House Bill 569 is now closed
at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill 643 FN
expanding number of Grafton County
Commissioners do I have a
motion uh the chair recognizes
representative stavis for a
motion thank you madam chair um I move
itl on HB 643 FN is there a second
representative Murphy I second that
thank you representative Murphy seconds
that motion discussion oh sorry would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Davis uh yes thank you
madam chair um this was another bill
where the sponsor uh uh didn't take the
time to show up to explain the thinking
behind this bill but even in his absence
we can say that it is an
unconstitutional bill in that it in it
levies a charge that isn't in wasn't in
existence before it's going to cost the
state money that the state just doesn't
have further comments discuss
seeing none the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
643 FN if you are in favor of that
motion you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to that motion you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock yes
representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative jard
yes representative grund
yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 643 FN is inexpedient to
legislate without objection that will go
on to the house consent calendar and the
committee report will be written by oh
no I was just going to say it's an FN so
doesn't it have to go on the regular
calendar that is correct yes so all
right thank you for pointing that out so
and um representative
stavis will write the report thank you
and with that the executive session on
House Bill 643 FN is now
closed steis and that's so you got
regular right
okay
okay at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill 125 Rel
relative to electing straford County
Commissioners at
large do I have a
motion representative frock yes do you
have a motion thank
you um regarding
hb125 IM move itl is there a second
second uh representative Walker seconds
that would you like to speak to your
emotion representative FR um
certainly uh this
bill is relative to electing straford
County Commissioners at
large
and it
is not consistent with the way the rest
of the county commissioner
are elected in the rest of the state
therefore it should be
ited Thank You Is there further
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill
125 if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman Donald yes
representative
Guthrie yes yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker
yes representative stavis yes
representative
Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund yes Madam chair
yes
the motion passes with a vote of 18 to
Zer the committee recommendation on
House Bill 125 is inexpedient to
legislate and since there's no fiscal
note that will go on to the consent
calendar without
objection and
representative frock would you like to
write the committee report I'd be very
happy to thank you thank you and with
that the executive session on House Bill
125 is now
closed at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill 544
local relative to an optional local
public safety assessment on certain room
occupancies Madam chair yes I would like
to make a
motion yes you may I move uh HB 544
local as inexpedient to legislate is
there a
second I'll second that representative
France seconds that representative
um Gilman would you like to speak to
your
motion let's
see oh part of it is that there isn't
really a way to for the municipalities
to be sure of what's Happening um there
was no explanation of who's tracking
short-term rentals or if they even fall
under this um weren't really sure how
the overnight stays were burdening the
uh property taxes of the town SS that
they that the properties are in
um and what happens for towns that have
water sewer
um Enterprise funds uh how that $2 would
be divided up uh amongst the
funds and that's it thank you is there
further comments or discussion
seeing none the motion before us is in
expedient to legislate on House Bill 544
local if you are in favor of this motion
you'll vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Alward yes
the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative
Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock yes
representative Colby
yes representative Jama
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grundt
yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 544 local is inexpedient to
legislate without objection the
recommendation will go on the house
consent calendar and the committee
report will be written
by representative Gilman thank
you and with that the chair closes the
executive session on House Bill 544
local
so the next spell that we're going to
exact has an amendment associated with
it so see if you can locate that that
would be um number 652
okay at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill 247
local authorizing municipalities to hold
a referendum on whether to allow
historic horse
racing at this time I would like to
offer Amendment
d652 to House Bill 247 local is there a
second
Madam chairwoman I second the motion or
the recommendation rather uh thank you
representative majority seconds um the
motion to accept this
amendment so this amendment
um addresses feedback that we received
during the hearing on this this um this
bill and as you recall there was a um
a concern to a lot to insert um the
provision for those operations which
were El
eligible um
to hold a license but the license yet
not had been issued so there were two
places in the bill as filed where um
that provision would needed to be
inserted and and the language in the
amendment
um provides for for that for those
operations is there a discussion on
this
okay seeing none the motion before us is
to accept Amendment
2025-the 247 local if you are in favor
of the amendment you will vote Yes if
you are opposed to accepting the
amendment you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France yes
representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative
frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard yes
representative grundt yes madame chair
yes the motion to accept the amendment
Amendment
2025-the
Madam chair like to pass ought to pass
as amend like to move ought to pass as
amended on HB 247 local thank you do we
have a
second who who was that representative
Gilman thank you is there representative
stavis would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you madam chair um this
is a version of a bill that CA came to
our committee in the last session um and
was not successful and I'm happy to uh
have it again this time to look at um
communities like mine in Lebanon now
have a casino that had we had this
option in place we probably wouldn't
have the casino right now um I think
that it is only prudent to give
residents the U option of having a
referendum on whether they want these
establishments in their communities or
not further
discussion
comments so I support the the the motion
the bill as amended because it it
provides an optin provision that is
similar that we have currently in
statute with regards to
Kino
further
discussion okay see seeing none the
motion before us is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 247 local if you
are in favor of that motion you'll vote
Yes if you are opposed to that motion
you'll vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative
Guri representative Dolan
yes representative Alward
yes the clerk vote Yes representative
France yes representative Caris
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker yes representative
stavis yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Z the committee recommendation on
House Bill 247 local is ought to pass
with Amendment and without objection
that recommendation will go on to the
house
calendar and who will write the
committee report representative Davis
thank
you and with that the chair close cles
the executive session on House Bill 247
local
at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill
123 relative to yield taxes let me read
the
bill sorry
that's House Bill 123 enabling
municipalities to tax standing wood and
Timber on land used for carbon
sequestration at this time I would like
to offer Amendment 202
5-06
54h to House Bill
123 is there a second I'll second that
representative Kosinski seconds that so
um this amendment here is one of of many
and it's the last
one
and what this amendment um does is it
um cleans up um some
definitions that need to be part of this
legislation it also
it also
um puts the provision for carbon
sequestration um under 79 colon
3 and it
also
provides um some other parameters um for
with regards to the the carbon
sequestration um of of
Timber so discussion on on this
particular um Amendment
representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman
um you know I I'm looking at I'm looking
at the audience see a few Smiles out
there this is this is a very serious
issue um but one that was new to to
several members here so it took a while
that the learning St curve seemed to be
steep uh for all of us whether you've
been here a long time or not this was
something that was new I think it should
have gone to ways and means but we had
that discussion tongue and cheek but
seriously also hopefully it is going to
go there as a second committee because I
think that's where where it belongs but
one of the one of the primary reasons
why I'm going to vote um in favor of the
amendment is really speaks to the bill
and the issue at large which is that uh
these revenues really need to be
captured by the local communities uh up
there who are otherwise hurting we we at
a time right now where um those revenues
are being lost they're being sold to
other states or maybe just and other
state
California um uh where these credits are
being sold to another state who are
reaping the benefits of our good
stewardship um I think that those
revenues should be captured by the state
of New Hampshire uh and for those
reasons I I can recommend or I can
support the recommendation of the
amendment thank you further comments
so I have a few comments and and so this
legislation before
us involves the the timber tax which we
already have and as as we know the
timber tax is assessed on Timber when it
is cut for sale so the assessment is
it's it's a yield tax and this is not a
new tax because under the carbon
sequestration program the timber is
being
sold however it's not being
cut so I in my mind it's very clear that
this is not a new tax it's what's new is
it's a new way to sell the timber
therefore it's appropriate that this
yield tax be assessed for trees that are
have been sequestered for the carbon um
for carbon
credits this is an important issue it
it's it's it's a new
issue that the states need to um address
through legislation and and through
policy and it's my understanding that
the prime sponsor and other legislators
and other individuals
um in the state have been working on
this issue for many years so while this
bill comes before us here and now in
this legislative session this is
something that people have been looking
into thinking about
discussing
and there was a bill last year that
established a carbon registry and this
would be a second piece of
legislation to um
address um the issue that this bill
seeks to
um I guess
solve
and to be clear we heard during during
the hearings we heard testimony
that as a result of carbon sequestration
program that municipalities are um the
revenue because of the fact that these
this Timber is being locked up in these
um
carbon in these contracts for carbon
credits that is um greatly affecting the
timber
industry and the harvesting and the a
large percentage of New Hampshire is
forested
and the timber industry is an important
industry in our
state and we need to um we need to
address this here and now and not kick
this can down the road any
further there um I I feel I've worked
very closely with the the prime sponsor
and other
Representatives as this bill um has been
worked on since since the hearing
and I am confident in in in the language
that is before us um today in this
amendment and I fully support it and for
those who are
concerned that it might not be on target
I would say that like any legislation
that
is brand new there's always the
opportunity for housekeeping bill in a
subsequent year and and to reiterate I'm
I'm very confident in in what this
amendment in this bill um would do and I
think it's important for the State of
New Hampshire and and our
citizens further
comments okay so y oh oh I'm sorry
representative grund so I'll be brief
but I just I want to say I appreciate
everything you said Madam chair
chairwoman I I agree with where you were
going with that and I have gone back and
forth and I have struggled with this one
for multiple weeks as I've talked to
many people and I kept going back to you
know the the effect on our industry um
looking at what is when you look at
business you look at what's a taxable
event and what triggers those things and
understanding the timber industry
starting to understand a little bit more
about how carbon sequestration falls
under I feel like it's cre at ated that
event so it falls under that yield tax
about the timber so I do support the
amendment in the Bill further comments
or
discussion representative
Davis thank you madam chair and I would
just like to um thank the speaker I
guess for sending this bill to our
committee because it's really kind of
expanded our Horizons and made us um
stretch intellectually in ways that we
don't normally have to and I I really do
appreciate
that further
comments I'm seeing none the motion
before us is to
accept
the amendment
2025-the
yes if you are opposed to the amendment
you will vote no the clerk will call
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Walker yes
representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund yes Madam chair
yes
amendment
2025-the
of 18 to
zero so the chair um do is there do I
have another
motion so the chair motions ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill
123 is there a second I'll second that
Madam chair Vice chairman McDonald
seconds that
motion I don't feel that I need to um
reiterate anything that I that I said
does anybody else have anything else
that they would like to
add seeing none the motion before us is
ought to pass with amendment to House
Bill
123 the Clark will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Elward yes the clerk votes yes
representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis yes
representative Gilman
yes representative majori yes
representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative Jama
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommend
Commendation on House Bill 123 is ought
to pass with
Amendment without objection that
committee recommendation will go on to
the house consent calendar and the
representative power will Author the
committee
report and with that the chair closes
the executive session on House Bill
two3 e
next the The Chair will open the
executive session on House Bill 554
enabling municipalities to choose
whether or not to place political
advertising on Municipal
property
do oh representative Gerard is
recognized for a motion thank you madam
chair I'd like to
offer amendment number
70h is there a second representative
Murphy second thank you madam chair I
second that thank you representative
Gerard would you like to speak to your
motion to accept the amendment yes I
would um as when we had the hearing a
few weeks ago one of the some of the
questions that came up was who is going
to be able to uh oversee where the signs
would would be placed and there was also
questioning as far as electioneering so
working with representative Murphy and
also I spoke with the prime sponsor of
the bill they were comfortable with the
amendment was being offered which would
basically allow the municipalities to
make their own decision whether they
allow or disallow the signs is based
upon local ordinance at that point and
the only part with the election heing
that got put in there was just so that
way the municipality didn't decide to
put something where they're not supposed
to put it so that way we make sure we
followed all the
rules thank you are there any comments
representative
Elward thank you Madame chairman um I
just noticed this sitting here uh for
the last 10
minutes the use of the words local sign
ordinances typically
um signs are regulated under zoning
ordinances in towns that have zoning
ordinance
and correct me if my
I'm wrong but zoning only regulates
private real property I don't think
zoning ordinances regulate Municipal
property and
so I don't think that's correct language
further
comments representative Walker
yeah in Rochester we have a signed
ordinance that's in the the zoning
ordinances B it's part of the site plan
review and so this
is basically what we're doing in
Rochester we mimic the state law so they
don't allow any in Rochester except on
private property but this would change
that
further comments representative Gilman
thank you madam chair um I think the
ordinance that's being referred to here
could be referred to here is one set by
the governing body uh for example exitor
has a an ordinance to do to deal with
winter parking a winter parking ban or
uh what parks can and can't have dogs
and this would fit into that I believe
excuse me um where signs can and can't
be placed and in fact
we also have something in our ordinance
about
that additional
discussion representative
Elward yes in our town it's they're
governed under our zoning
ordinance
so the zoning ordinance
governs personal real
property not Municipal
property so I I have trouble with the
frases and I can't support the
amendment further comments
representative frock thank you madam
chair uh representative Elward is in
fact correct in that um Municipal
governments state government federal
government are exempt from all local
zoning unless the property is used for
commercial purposes
pretty sure about
that further
comments I have a
comment and it's similar to
representative Walker my understanding
that this amendment would
simply
codify the F the fact that
municipalities can establish where or we
not
signs political signs can can be placed
I know that in the the town that I live
in they currently do that with regards
to political signs they have a local
ordinance that says you can put them
here but you can't put them over here so
to me this is not changing the statute
that much except for saying specifically
that municipalities can make these
determinations and we have this in
writing within the
law so I support this amendment further
comments representative
Elward in response to your comment um
you said that you have an ordinance that
says the signs can be placed here or
there are you referring to here and
there as real property or Municipal
property
it's Municipal property is my
understanding thank
you further discussion or comments
representative
grund so in our town as well under our
zoning we do have a signed ordinance of
where it's permitted to Place Town Place
signs on Town property and it par and
says where you cannot as well um and
it's any sign so it doesn't hurt the
First Amendment rights um but it does
just specify where you can and cannot so
it does exactly what this is talking
about further
comments okay seeing none the motion
before us is to accept Amendment 20
25-57 to House Bill 544 if you are in
favor of accepting the amendment then
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
accepting the amendment then you will
vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie
no representative Dolan
yes representative Elward no
the clerk vote
Yes representative France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock yes
representative Colby
yes representative gerna
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grunt
yes Madam chair
yes Amendment
four is accepted with a vote of 16-2 do
I have a
motion representative Gerard I'd like to
make a motion of
otpa for House Bill
554 thank you is there a
second representative Murphy is
recognized thank you madam chair I
second that
motion thank you representative Gerard
would you like to speak to your motion
I just believe that this is going to
help municipalities to be able to fall
under the First Amendment um we're again
last fall we were one of the communities
that were uh cited as from the AG's
office that we weren't allowed to be
able to put Municipal signs out on
Municipal property where we had been
doing it so this is hopefully just to
try to clarify what we were already
doing in our
community further discussion or
comments seeing none the motion before
us is to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 554 if you're in favor of that
motion you will vote Yes if you're
opposed to the motion you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald yes representative
Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk vote Yes represent Presa
France
yes representative kazinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana yes
representative Gerard
yes representative grund yes Madam chair
yes so the motion passes with a vote of
18 to Zer the committee recommendation
on House Bill 554 is ought to pass with
Amendment without objection the
recommendation will go on the house
consent calendar
and representative Gerard would you like
to write the committee report thank you
and with that the executive session on
House Bill 554 is now closed
at this time the chair opens the
executive session on House Bill 512 FN
relative to preventing munici Municipal
Employees from being paid under multiple
Municipal contract
simultaneously do I have a motion
representative Murphy is recognized for
a motion thank you madam chair I like
make a motion for HB 5112 FN to be itl
do I have a
second representative
stavis thank you madam chair I'd like to
second that motion thank you
representative stavis seconds
that representative Murphy would you
like to speak to your motion thank you
madam chair uh there were a couple
things one the prime sponsor was not
there and which is is a big deal for me
and the other part of it is it would
limit especially school districts of
sharing superintendence and other
Personnel that they may see fit between
the the two districts and also some
towns also share Town clerks and what
have
you thank you is there further
discussion or
comments I'm seeing
none the motion before us is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 512 FN if you
are in favor of that motion you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes the clerk
votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Walker yes
representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerna
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grundt yes
Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Zer the committee recommendation on
House Bill 512 FN is inexpedient to
legislate that will not go onto the
house calendar because it has a fiscal
note so it will go onto the regular
calendar and who will write the report
representative Murphy Madam chair I'll
write that report thank you
and with that the executive session on
House Bill 512 FN is now closed
at this time the chair will open the
executive session on House Bill
562 relative to the filing of vacant
positions on elected Municipal boards
and school
boards do I have a motion representative
kazinski is recognized for a motion
thank you madam chair I'll make a motion
to itl House Bill 562 thank you is there
a second mam chair I second the motion
representative majority second motion
representative kazinski would you like
to speak to your motion yes thank you
madam chair I think this uh proposal
proposed bill would handcuff the
authorized board or the appointing board
in the case of uh filling a
vacancy I could see where they might not
even uh consider somebody that's ran in
the last three elections because that
wouldn't open up the requirement that
they offer it to the runner up in one of
the previous elections and if that
person is a fringe type uh
candidate U they might not be able to
have the person that might be best
suited to fill the position for the town
or School District thank
you further comments or discussion
representative
grund thank you so the other piece um
and I want I appreciate the uh to me the
will of the voter is the will of the
voter at the time of a vote not three
years afterwards um the other piece is
it never addressed Cooperative school
districts so if that falls under RSA 671
colon 33 comma 4 and that has to do with
so in my town we actually had this
happen um so hean School District
Amhurst has five School me school board
members Mont Vernon has two one resigned
from Mont Vernon one person from Vernon
cannot choose the other appointee so it
goes to the board of Selectmen this does
not address that at
all thank you further
comments representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman and uh
the question also came up what happens
if there was a tie in one of those
elections um who would it go to there
was no answer to that question either so
they
mechanic which has happened I'm well
aware you're well aare of
it so there there there are I get what
the what the sponsor is trying to do I
certainly get what he's trying to do but
the mechanics of this bill don't get
them there thank you further comments I
I would agree that the the bill is not
ready for prime time there's a there's a
lot of um technical issues that that
weren't uh um perhaps thought of and
addressed so I support the
recommendation of itl ADD additional
comments seeing none the motion before
us is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill
562 if you're in favor of that motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
rooll vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes the clerk
votes yes representative France yes
representative kazinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori
yes representative frock yes
representative Colby
yes representative gerna yes
representative Gerard yes representative
grund yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 562 is inexpedient to
legislate without objection that
recommendation you oh without I thought
you were objecting with without
objection that recommendation will go
onto the house consent calendar
and representative kazinski will write
the committee report thank you and with
that the chair will close the H the
executive session on House Bill
562 next the chair will open the ex Ive
session on House Bill
490 relative to indemnification from
municipalities adopting policies to
address
homelessness do I have a
motion representative ger I move itl on
HB 490 is there a second I'll second it
representative Walker seconds that
motion representative ger would you like
to speak to your motion sure um well I
think we can all appreciate um the issue
that this is trying to help with the
homelessness crisis that we have here in
New Hampshire I think taking it to the
point of no liability for the M for the
municipalities um is just going a bit
kind of too far and there's some
circumstances especially when you get
into intention and what's intentional
and not um which is why I'm moving for
itl Thank You Is there further comments
or
discussion so a concern that I have with
this is whenever we're um this would
fall under the realm of Public Safety
and also there there may be health
concerns related to this type of
legislation and um as legislators
whenever that comes into play we we
should um be mindful and take note and
like um representative Jama said that I
feel that this this goes a step too far
so I will be supporting the um motion of
in expedient to legislate further
comments representative
stavis thank you madam chair I found
myself wondering as I thought about this
bill what other classes of
people cannot sue a municipality if they
have been harmed by that municipality
and it seemed to me that at the end of
the day this is a discriminatory
Bill further comments or discussion
seeing none the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
490 if you are in favor of that motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Alber yes
the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative kazinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock yes
representative
Colby
yes representative jamana yes
representative Gerard
yes representative grundt yes Madam
chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Zer the committee recommendation on
House Bill 490 is inexpedient to
legislate without objection that
recommendation will go on to the house
consent
calendar and representative
gerana would you like to author the
committee report thank you and with that
the executive session on House Bill 490
is now
closed the chair now opens the exec Ive
session on House Bill 668 FN local
authorizing municipalities to hold a
referendum to resend the licenses of
historic horse racing
facilities do I have a
motion Madam chairman I move for itl do
I have a
second
representative majori seconds that
representative McDonald would you like
to speak to your
motion yes thank you uh we voted on HP
247 L which does a process to uh get
approved for the horse racing and I
think should consideration be given if
once a company does that spends $100,000
a million dollars putting up Casino
there should be some safe check or
specific guidelines how that license
could be
rescinded and that's all I've got to say
thank you further comments discussion
seeing none the motion before us it is
an expedient to legislate on House Bill
668 FN local if you are in favor of that
motion you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to the motion you will vote no
the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Alward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Walker yes
representative stavis yes representative
Gilman yes representative majori
yes representative frock yes
representative Colby
yes representative jamana
yes representative Gerard yes
representative grund yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
house bills
668 FN local is inexpedient to legislate
that bill will need to go onto the
regular calendar because that is a
fiscal note and and representative
McDonald will you write the committee
report yes I will thank
you and with that the chair closes the
executive session on House Bill 668 FN
local so at this point in time that
concludes our publicly noticed business
for today and I do have afternoon our
favorite afternoon
announcements so a house session has
been scheduled for Thursday March 6th
and I would ask you to please hold open
Monday March 10th for executive sessions
only because we just concluded all our
um public hearings for the 60 bills plus
one non- gerain amendment that had been
referred to this
committee yay so um Monday March
10th SEC um that's will be for executive
sessions only and not notably this date
will become official once it's been
scheduled and publicly noticed which I
plan to do by noon on
Wednesday uh representative State I have
a few more announcements but did you
have something okay um additionally
committee reports are due um for me by
noon to the committee uh services staff
so while I know that that is not does
not give everybody 48 Hours exactly if
at all possible if you could get your
committee reports to me so that I could
submit that that would be um much
appreciated and okay one other thing
with regards to amendments so I would
kindly ask as a reminder if you plan to
request an amendment from OS please let
me know before you um make that request
not after and the reason I specify that
is because there may be other members of
this committee who have the same
idea and so um I just want to make sure
that we're not um submitting the same
amendments and utilizing the resources
of OLS so those are the only
announcements that I have and
representative stavis did you have a
question or later any other
questions okay well seeing none the
meeting of Municipal and County
government committee is now adjourned
thank you and have a great week and see
you on
Thursday e